don't get married until you're 35 making
six figures a year in shape going to the
gym consistently and half with 50 girls
Russian fitter podcasters that mainly
discuss gender roles dating and
self-improvement except in a pretty
controversial way Society will still
prop her up and tell her you deserve
that multi-millionaire six foot three
guy even though you're ugly well there's
a lot that we agree with there's also a
lot that we disagree with anything it's
possible we can walk outside of the door
and get struck by lightning as possible
I see that to say we feel like it's our
duty as podcasters to have an open
discussion and hear different
perspectives on topics we might not
otherwise get to talk about maybe we'll
learn a thing or two we understand that
this is not our normal episode but as
always Joy we'll do our best to read as
many of your comments as possible let us
know what you think of this down below
thank you guys so much don't forget to
like subscribe and also a big thank you
to our sponsor netsuite look we always
talk about businesses here on the
channel and as a business owner myself I
understand the struggles of managing
multiple different systems and juggling
countless spreadsheets but that could
all be solved if you were to use
netsuite netsuite is an integrated
business software that helps with CRM
resource planning and more there's a
reason why netsuite is the number one
Cloud Financial system they bring
everything your business needs in real
time and all in one place a software
like netsuite provides the visibility
and control you need to make better
decisions faster saving you both energy
and time as we all know time is money
over 36 000 companies have already
upgraded to netsuite to help gain
control and visibility over their
finances inventory HR e-commerce and so
on so no more manual data entry or
scattered data all over the place just
pure efficiency and productivity so that
that way you could focus on where your
time is really the best spent Plus for
the first time ever you could defer
payments of a full netsuite
implementation for six months that means
no payments or interest for a half a
year whether you're a small business
owner or an entrepreneur you shouldn't
miss out on the deal head over to
netsuite.com iced to take advantage of
this exclusive financing offer today
again that's netsuite.com iced
netsuite.com iced remember to keep your
business efficient and take it to the
next level with netsuite thank you so
much and now let's begin the podcast we
are fresher fit welcome back to iced
coffee hour let's go live baby let's get
it well except we're not live you guys
do live right oh yeah yeah yeah so fresh
don't say that no no it's fine we could
we could keep going cool this is great
thank you guys so much
you guys are here in Las Vegas live in
this yes we are in the studio yeah it's
exciting for us okay uh we have a lot to
discuss one thing is that you guys are
serial entrepreneurs should I say right
and you guys invest in real estate as
well yes yes definitely okay so so walk
me through your entrepreneurial journey
and how you got to where you are right
now so basically I'm from a small island
called Barbados right and back in
Barbados there's not much going on with
entrepreneurship it's basically you go
to school get a job get a career right
so what happened was I started watching
YouTube videos online at Saul green
Stefan of course I saw other creators
what was one of the first videos you saw
me I'm curious you literally in uh I
think are showing a house showing or
whatever talking about your first uh
entrepreneurship getting your first
property I believe that was the first
one oh my gosh so that was early 2017.
yeah like the beginning that was sub 20
30 000 subscribers yeah videos yeah so
that and you said that was an open house
that one open house yeah I think it was
you just talking about your feelings
about real estate in that uh close to
one-on-one with your audience pretty
much and you're still an agent at the
time too yeah and that was that was my
first video by by the way that I took
down wow I took it down you can't even
find it anymore he was probably your
only viewer in Barbados yeah
that could be it that's so funny so
hearing your struggles what you went
through and learning for all the
creators as well I was you know what
I've decided I need to do more for my
family and for myself so I knew Coming
to America was my only option so I came
from Barbados to America looked at real
estate how to invest how to make money
as an entrepreneur social media all that
stuff and what happened was over time I
was making money from my job saving for
a property and what I do I house hacks
my first property FHA alone wow I got a
Triplex here in now Miami that's what
worked out for a while but how much were
you making at the time when you bought
your tripod 15 an hour what what luckily
for for me the job uh offered unlimited
overtime so we're crazy hours 14 hour
days every single day no breaks over a
whole year save that money I bought my
first profit yeah and so over time
you're getting a time and a half right
it was able to stack what job allows you
to do unlimited overtime like that don't
they usually cap you they do but
remember it
so they first came to Miami they were
pretty much like brand new yeah and they
were like you know what we have limited
employees but we have a lot of work to
do so you know what for you guys for
giving you unlimited over time I said
wow unlimited I'll take it so that
started my savings Journey that's really
cool what about you uh so before the
YouTube stuff I was actually a special
agent with Homeland Security so what I
did was like criminal investigations
with everything from like human smack
human smuggling to human trafficking to
drug trafficking anything like Mexican
cartel related I started in Laredo Texas
and then I moved to Miami to the Miami
Field office started up the the podcast
slash the YouTube stuff and you know
they brought me in and they're like hey
you know you're saying controversial
stuff on the internet you got to pick
one and then you know I ended up going
the entrepreneur route and then you know
the channel started to do well
and when I left the government the first
thing I did was actually buy real estate
and uh I took like all my money out of
my um tsp Thrift Savings Account for the
government employees and I bought my
first house uh and basically ever since
then just been buying houses what was
that like for you doing like you know
drugs smuggling all that sort of stuff
how is that for me I I would see stuff
like that and not be able to comprehend
it like I'd be able to go home and just
be like I can't talk to anybody like if
I see anything online like that I just
yeah it was it was it was a tough job
it's one of those jobs where you have to
take it home with you yeah uh you know
I'd bring like my laptop back and write
reports and you're working all the time
because you're working like odd hours
right you got to take home car and
everything so you basically live the job
and especially when I was on the
Southwest border we're working all the
time because you could get called out
you know if they catch someone at the
bridge with drugs or they catch someone
smugging in illegal aliens basically
you're the think of it as like you got
the Department of Homeland Security and
then you got border patrol and you got
Customs those are like the uniformed
officers then we were the special agents
which is think of them as detectives so
you would follow up on any investigation
that they caught because if someone is
smuggling in drugs or someone is
smuggling in illegal aliens or smuggling
guns or whatever there's an organization
behind that that needs to be
investigated so I did that for almost a
decade and then I left the government in
2020 uh and then
because the podcast started to take off
at that time so I kind of had to pick
one how did you two meet
we met through a mutual friend actually
another YouTuber named solo tv84 shout
out to him uh he we both live in Miami
and he was basically like hey man you
need to go with this guy a fresh prince
CEO he's out there in Brooklyn the same
area which is like the neighborhood that
we both live in and uh we got on an
Instagram call together and we just
basically bonded over uh womanizing yeah
basically talking about chicks and like
oh you're good women me too okay let's
figure this out so yeah but just add the
little context here as well it's funny
because back then right I got your
course I'll make a channel for YouTube
right and I was doing prank videos so
plug your strategy towards prank videos
and start blowing up so I spent hours on
YouTube at Starbucks learning how to you
know make thumbnails you know invest in
like real YouTube and that started my
journey on YouTube as well so thank you
girlfriend wow for real man that was
amazing that is not a plain testimonial
everyone
yeah so helped a lot that's that's OG
fans yeah Academy you never really
realized just like the impact of even
just putting it like that one video the
ripple effect that has throughout
everything is insane is inspiring bro
thank you I really appreciate that so
I'm curious because you talked about a
decade in that job did you ever see
anything I'm sure you probably did
that's just like crazy like any any
story that comes to I mean there's a
million stories I could think of uh
because we used to arrest I was drug
traffickers arm Smugglers cartel people
I I think if I could give you one quick
story that is going to take up the
entire podcast one I remember was I was
it was like a Sunday I was like on duty
which is when you're on duty it means
that like they can call you in for
anything right like if someone something
happens you got to go deal with it so
they ended up uh border troyd caught
this guy and he said I need to talk to
her to an HSI agent blah blah I have
some information to give so I was like
all right so I was like whatever I'll go
and I'll respond so I went over the
station this is back in Laredo Texas go
sit down and talk with him and he starts
telling me about how he's like The
Bodyguard for this cartel one of these
high-ranking uh cartel guys but at the
time it was the Los Zetas that ran that
part of Mexico and Nuevo Laredo this is
back like 2015 ish uh and he was uh
guarding someone I think named Z4 anyone
who was one of the top guys and he was
telling me how like he was a sicario and
he was a bodyguard and well he used to
tell me what he said was like we used to
get a bonus and the bonus was he used to
get extra money for every Mexican Marine
that he killed and what he would do is
he would like slice off a piece of her
ear or a finger or whatever he'd bring
it back to his boss and he got uh extra
money for every body part that he
brought from one of the Mexican Marines
because there was a war going on between
those two factions at the time and he
was saying like hey I want to provide
information uh this is years ago now so
it's it's done but I want to provide
information I can't go back to Mexico
they're going to kill me blah blah blah
but just the thing that shocked me was
just like how matter of fact he was
about like what his duties were what he
did Etc so I called another agent that
was more you know versus at the time and
he was like oh yeah I know this guy is
so they came in and they took it over so
I was like all right cool I couldn't
handle that yeah like that that's to
like the the disassociation between like
that's that's a person yeah like their
whole life led us to the point of being
basically used as a bonus yeah like it's
insane his job was solely to like they
was to travel in motorcades right and
his job was anytime the Marines would
start to attack them or whatever his job
was to create the version Let the boss
get away because they all had armored
vehicles and then he would you know
create the diversion he just like
started shooting at them or whatever and
the more Marines he killed the more he
was able to go to the boss and Mexican
Marines in this case and uh get a bonus
he got paid for per body part he brought
do you think constantly being subjected
to people like that and experiences like
that it could give you a pretty
desensitized view towards suffering or a
cynical view towards life uh I would say
it made me aware of the evils that human
beings are capable of
um so nothing really surprises me at
this point
um but it made me look at the world for
what it really is and you know
unfortunately there are some really bad
people out there it's not all sunshines
and rainbows do you feel like that is
the way the world really is I mean I
know that exists to a certain degree
yeah
um but don't you feel like the good
outweighs that or do you feel like just
being subject to that you realize like
hey this is out there we gotta protect
against this I I would say you know
there's good people there's bad people
uh
there's a good outweigh the bad
I would say
man because there's so many criminals
that don't get caught you know what I
mean like like we you know we always had
this funny quote when I worked uh in law
enforcement saying we only catch the
dumb ones but there's so many people
that don't get caught or don't get
prosecuted because it didn't meet a
certain threshold or it wasn't sexy
enough for the U.S attorney's office or
whatever so I would say there is more
good but there is a sizable amount of
people that are bad as well which is it
and I didn't realize that until I got on
the job like just how many bad people
should be aware what's happening in the
world at least yeah it made me look at
the world more objectively versus
idealistically So based off of my very
limited perspective because I never grew
up experiencing anything like that as a
very normal childhood by American
Western standards yeah
um I just believed in like the good of
mankind and I still believe in it like
I'm an optimist I think 99.99 of the
people out there are good humans no one
has bad intent but of course that's just
my own that's yeah I mean and you would
be right a good amount of the time but
you know there are you know there are
people out there that have nefarious
intentions unfortunately and uh and the
thing is the crazy part is like you you
won't even know because a big part of
for them why they're able to evade law
enforcement because you don't know and
they've kind of fly under the radar have
you ever seen any criminals like that
that you knew they're guilty they did it
we know what they're up to but we just
don't have enough on them to prosecute
oh yeah like what are some of those
examples yeah so what we've always said
is that it's not what you know it's what
can you prove yeah and at the federal
level right so there's two different
types of law enforcement to make it
simple like you got the state and local
law enforcement right who goes through
the Ada or assistant District Attorney's
office and then you got the feds right
where you go through U.S United States
attorney's office and at the federal
level you got FBI DEA HSI who I used to
work for and all the federal agencies
when it comes to doing Federal cases
prosecutors are very picky about what
cases they're going to take because they
have a very high success rate so you
need to bring a lot more evidence to an
investigation at the federal level than
for the state level now with that said
this is why the feds don't lose because
when the ausa takes a case on they
pretty much know they're going to win
that's why when people do get convicted
of a federal crime they do 89 of the
time and they rarely take it to trial
because the feds have such a good record
I guess when it comes to Prosecuting
cases interesting they're very selective
on what they take though ausas are divas
I've always said it because they only
take the sexiest cases yeah reputation
depending on what U.S attorney's Office
you're in so like for example like the
southern district of New York is one of
the most famous Federal prosecutorial
offices right that's where they went
after the mafia that's where they went
after the 911 guys you know
uh Etc like all the biggest criminals
organized crime typically New York uh
southern district of New York so they
have a very big reputation where they
want to go after big criminal
organizations right they're not going to
take anything less than that so the
ausas are going to be fairly selective
on what they take oh is this guy
endangered Community ah no it's good
give it to the stage all right that's
how it look at anything it also has
anything to do with media attention as
well for sure absolutely I've always
said it it's marketing yeah the feds are
Cloud Chasers I mean like if you know if
the if an agency is able to go after
someone that has a lot of money or a lot
of status and put them behind bars for
you know whether it was like fraud or
you know some violent crime or whatever
they'll do it if it's going to bring
positive attention to the United States
attorney's office or to the agency that
arrests them although before we go into
that I do have to say one of the things
that I've been talking about non-stop
here in the channel is the importance of
building a good credit score I'm sure
there's a lot of you watching that are
just getting started on your journey
your young adults you want to improve
and maybe you don't like the idea of
taking on debt well in that case if you
want to build your credit one of the
best and simplest Solutions Solutions
out there is Fizz with fizz you can now
build your credit and even earn cash
back using a debit card so you could
build your credit without the
traditional risks of acquiring more debt
then from there thanks to their autopay
feature your bill is paid off
automatically every single day this is
also a lot different from the
traditional credit cards out there
because they make money solely from
their merchant interchange fees not from
their card holders this means that
you're able to enjoy all the benefits
without any hidden fees or charges the
best part about all of this is that
signing up for Fizz is incredibly easy
and simple there's no credit check no
security deposit no cosigner required
Fizz also reports your activity to all
three major credit bureaus helping you
build your credit score just like you
would with a regular credit card so sign
up for Fizz today and instantly add your
Fizz card to Apple pay I would also be
sure to use the code iced coffee because
the first thousand people that sign up
get a free ten dollars you shouldn't
miss out on the exclusive offer all the
information and links are down below in
the description to get started thank you
so much enjoy and now let's get back to
the podcast so let's talk about where
exactly you two were in your own
independent in life when you first met
like if you could just give me a little
synopsis of like where you were
financially where you were just like in
general Yeah so basically uh starting
from Chick-fil-A making seven dollars an
hour working at uh taking phone calls
and then upgrading to uh Dublin
insurance and then tech company I was
making roughly 15 bucks an hour and uh I
was on YouTube as well on the side
making good money from that
um and then I met Myron from doing the
podcast with Solo TV to four yep so
basically I had property they get 50 an
hour and then my YouTube side business
property was Cash Loan yes cool and then
the YouTube side business why did you
not go all in on that if it was
profitable and like you said you were
going viral when you're only making 15
an hour well it's funny because like at
that point I made like a couple Bible
videos but like every video was viral so
you know it used to be make out of
Revenue well like it doesn't always sell
on every single video yep so for me it's
like you know what is it going well yeah
but I don't know if it can go all the
way in as yet sure okay and then you and
for me so when I I met him I had a
Fitness business and I was still working
for the feds so when you work for the
feds you have to do something called
Outsider approval right to get outside
employment so I started my Fitness
business
once I got the green light you know
because I got to make sure you don't do
a conflict of interest or whatever like
you know you can't work at a defense law
firm if you're a criminal investigator
right so they got to make sure they
clear it et cetera so I started Fitness
business and also like life coaching uh
got that approved so I was doing that
while simultaneously working on the job
as well
um and then
as as YouTube started to take off that's
kind of why I had to make my decision of
what I'm going to do at the time working
for the government I was making about
120 130 000 per year so it wasn't bad I
was and what I did was I took that money
invested into the Fitness business and
that's how I was able to get that kick
started as well so I was able to double
my income by the time I how do you have
the time for that dude you know that's a
good question yeah luckily um so shout
out to my my mentor with the Fitness
business Brandon Carter he basically
taught us how to like scale it where it
was all automated yeah Brandon Carter
yeah fantastic yeah yeah I like him yeah
um so I was able to have my Fitness
business I was doing it um through an
app yeah right so everything was kind of
like there where the you know client was
able to sign in how many calories they
got to eat what they got to do for
workouts it was automated then I'll
check in with them once or twice a week
and then um I was also doing the uh the
government stuff and then the podcasting
as well so it did start to get a little
bit crazy and then you know obviously
they brought me in or whatever so it's
kind of like a blessing in disguise but
yeah I was working government making
about 120 130k and then I was making
about the same thing with the Fitness
business so I was able to take that
money from the government invest in that
business and scale it up and it was
doing pretty well so by the time I left
I was making like 300 and you had
problems as well no I didn't buy my
first property till I left the
government got it because my goal right
so when I left the government I was like
damn I'm losing out on a six-figure
career what am I going to do here I saw
the first thing I was like all right I
need to replace it with real estate
which actually I watched your video how
to buy real estate step by step which
that helped quite a bit yeah yeah I did
step by step by step which was fantastic
so I pulled that money out of my my tsp
and bought that first property and yeah
ended up working out but my goal was
once I got out the government I was like
okay I need to replace that 100K per
year with real estate passively so I've
been able to like triple that now so
it's great so I had a YouTube channel
that was a fitness channel and then he
had a YouTube channel with his pranks
and then we started doing a podcast on
how helping guys become more attractive
and getting girls then we realized there
was a void guys were like they were
struggling with girls not just because
maybe they didn't have game or whatever
but they had a bunch of things not and
not in line right to be attracted you
know not focusing on money wrong wrong
being broke being fat and thinking that
they're going to get an attractive girl
so we're like dude we need to do a
podcast to teach guys how to become
attractive and all aspects so they
become the complete package so that's
when we kind of like collided and then
we changed my YouTube channel which was
a fitness channel into the podcast
Channel and then his channel we
converted to I think the first channel
that we have now so what did you find to
strike us forward most with those
viewers that started really helping your
guys's success on the podcast like was
there a specific topic or I think being
relatable because most people are
talking about Authority standpoint
they're like so far gone I can't really
relate to that person but us being
regular dudes on the street you know
wanted to become better men become
successful yeah they kind of like
resonated with that and then for example
we showed results we'll go and double
this all the time and we'll get going to
the podcast like how they doing this
once again we're in the field doing the
work so them seeing that you know what
it's possible I correlate to this person
so I'm curious what prompted that
because usually what happens from what
I've seen is that and you go through a
breakup or something like that and you
realize like I really got to work on
myself I got to get better at this I'm
lacking in this area like what prompted
that to make that change for you guys um
to self-improof yeah so we live in Miami
Florida and Miami is one of the most
competitive cities when it comes to you
know dating and getting girls because
the problem is that as a guy there
you're competing with all the most elite
Men You're competing with athletes
celebrities entertainers Etc like
they're all there they all have a second
home there and Florida has exploded in
the real estate market so even more
people are coming to Miami nowadays
right and the thing is in our Niche
right the the dating Niche or whatever
self-improvement like a lot of guys that
teach guys how to get girls live in
foreign places they live in Brazil they
live in Colombia they live in Thailand
they live in Philippines you know uh
they live in Eastern Europe where you
know I'll be honest like a lot of the
girls are hotter they have certain
habits that aren't conducive to you know
they have certain how do I say this
characteristics that make them better
girlfriends for long-term relationships
right versus being here in the west so
we're one of the few guys that are not
only in the United States but we're in a
very competitive city where the girls
are super it's very competitive and the
girls are super hypergamous and
hypergamy is just the the want to date a
guy that's better than yourself so we're
relatable like he said because we're
actually dating in the United States in
the west
um and we're doing it in a very
competitive of City so that's kind of
where uh the void filled in but we the
where it came from was to get attractive
girls especially in competitive cities
you have to be your best version of
yourself you have to be so what were the
most common problems that you found in
your viewers
501 hygiene hygiene and being fat yeah
well let's let's stop there let's let's
talk about being fat okay from what I've
seen it doesn't really make that big of
a difference if you could overcome that
with confidence if you are so confident
in yourself I've seen throughout my
career in real estate some of the real
estate developers there were overweight
some of them severely overweight yeah
and I've seen them with so many
different women and they have no problem
they're just charismatic they're funny
you want to be around them they draw
people in I haven't really seen that
make that big of an effect so I'll say
this right you have a point however
think about desire yeah for example I'm
half Charisma I might be confident but
like desire wise does she really want me
so for example a lot guys ever have
money right let's see you know what yeah
but then work myself I got money and
what goes warming however what did what
do they really want so my thing is like
even though you're you're not in shape
if you're in shape I'm telling you right
now it broadens your horizons because
once again you get more quality girls
and as well they deserve you as the
person couldn't you also argue that if
you are overweight and you just that
isn't something that's of importance to
you that they'll see that too and they
say oh it's not important to him but
he's confident and he has his life
together he has all these other
qualities it's not going to make that
big of a difference well so I'll be
honest about this a lot of times when
you see these fat guys with a girl one
of two things either they have money or
they're paying for sex or paying these
chicks I've seen you I I'll tell you
like because there's a lot of tricks
there's there's a lot of there's an
entire we I don't know if you guys want
to go into this but there's like an
entire sugar baby culture tricking
culture where girls are pseudo escorts
Etc so
um like a lot of these rich guys that
aren't like that that are fat or
whatever yeah confidence and it you know
works and everything else like that but
we want guys to be a complete package
because let's say you have money and you
have confidence right but you're fat
well you're gonna alienate a large
portion of women that just won't give
you a chance because you don't meet a
physical requirement like you're fat
like it is what it is you'll turn you'll
just turn them off and on top of that
the girl a lot of times you're not going
to get that same you know
visceral desire or attraction or arousal
from that woman you're not going to get
the best out of her and we tell guys we
want you to get the best out of your
chick yeah I guess my argument would be
that there's so many people out there
that it doesn't matter if you've you
know maybe attract 10 versus 30 because
10 is still a lot when you consider this
like seven billion people in the world I
will probably agree that there's I'm
just intuitively a larger contingent of
women that are more attracted to a
non-fat person yeah there are people
that are attracted to a fat guy but I
also think like I also don't know
yeah I guess that's all well here's the
thing like I would I would agree with
that yeah so in today's day and age the
issue is that girls are a lot more
selective now than they ever were
because women make their own money
feminism has kind of come in and women
are strong and independent they have
this narrative that Beyonce's kind of
fed them where they're not settling
right strong and independent what do I
need you for you better come in and
bring some my life and what's happened
is a lot of guys are ostracized in the
dating game now because a lot of guys
quite frankly just don't measure up for
a lot of girls and a lot of girls have
how do I basically an over-inflated
sense of self-worth you can attribute
this to dating apps you can attribute
this to Instagram you can attribute this
to the internet Tick Tock Etc all of
this has kind of come in and made women
feel in general that they deserve the
most and they deserve a top tier guy
because they might have data to talk to
your guy maybe they met that's actually
the top tier guy maybe they hung out
with one maybe they got invited to a
boat party maybe they met a celebrity
here so women nowadays have access to
the highest levels of men so a guy that
was averaged five foot eight five foot
nine making 50k per year might have been
able to find a girlfriend or a wife 10
15 years ago but nowadays it's a lot
harder for the average guy and has been
shown in the studies right one in three
men hasn't had sex in a year or is a
virgin between 18 and 30 women swipe
right only about five percent of the men
on Tinder
um guys are really suffering when it
comes to dealing with opposite gender
and women on the other hand you know
it's it's great for them because you
know with the internet social media Etc
they're able to have access to men that
they would have never had before so so
being in the dating pool right now I
don't really experience that I think a
lot of girl rolls like you can say of
course that yeah there is like this
movement right now where it's like you
know your dessert you you just should
you deserve the most you're like that
you're you're the best or whatever yeah
the woman I see that just scrolling on
the feed and everything yeah but I will
also say there's a ton of stuff that's
put out there on Tick Tock Instagram
YouTube all that stuff that kind of
shuts down women as well for example
like an extremely attractive girl
posting selfies on her Instagram and
then girls comparing themselves to this
woman you know like feeling poorly about
themselves that does happen but still
think about all the girls on Instagram
right for example let's start going to
Idaho she's maybe like a smooth seven or
six on a scale of one out of ten and
like she's legit like average girl
however let's say for example she gets a
damn from like Drake or three songs you
know flight of California I'll fly you
out that one experience transfers
everything so my thing is yeah but I
don't think that really happens that
often oh you'd be surprised you'd be
surprised by that you'd be surprised
especially in La bro yeah
you'd be surprised dude girls in major
cities have more opportunities than ever
before like the internet that has
changed the game I talked about this in
my book why women deserve less by the
way but uh in general
um like girls in big cities have more
opportunities than ever before and the
thing is is that they don't really have
to prove themselves anymore like if
they're hot they have an Instagram
profile
Etc guys that are Elite are gonna hit
them up and say yo let's hang out and
let's go into like a dream scenario
right let's say you turn 18 right and
all of a sudden girls are offering to
fly you out to California to hook up
with them you're getting offered to go
on boats you're getting offered to get
your bills paid you're getting offered
to go on extravagant dates at Salt Bay's
restaurant and you haven't done anything
in life you just graduated high school
what would you how what kind of person
would that make you you would feel
entitled you would think you're better
than the other uh than the opposite
gender you would think that you're
special you would think that you deserve
all this just because you exist and that
is a lot of modern day women is it all
no but a lot of them do have their
mindset isn't it just the market value
that people place on on looks at this
point to me that just seems like that's
existed since the beginning of time yeah
but with social media and internet it's
m simplified it to another degree
because it used to be a girl had to step
outside to be able to get that attention
to validation now she doesn't have to
leave the comfort of her own home she's
able to effectively scale her dating
options the same could be true about a
guy a guy could build his entire career
without ever setting foot out of the
house could make a ton of money
big difference men have to earn their
value women are given their value so as
a man even if you become successful make
money you're still gonna have to go out
there talk to the girl Court the girl
not stink not be a weirdo not stutter
over your words still display some
semblance of confidence Still Still
display some kind of competence so for
men uh you have to earn your ability to
date the opposite gender versus women
don't I don't know about that I think if
you're honestly just an attractive dude
who's fit it's the exact same thing he's
an attractive girl that's fit it's the
exact like really no yes that's an
experiment yeah go on Tinder right make
your profile you're attractive you're a
fit right yes fat not as attractive I
guarantee you should get way more likely
yeah but Alice I will also say guys
libido is way higher so if guys are
swiping on Tinder like they're oh the
swipe on anything exactly anything but
but that doesn't change yeah once I want
you you might yeah those are very
selective because everyone they'll swipe
on they match yeah pretty much literally
bro and they did a study on this they
took a guy right that was like top tier
looks in shape it said Etc model type
looks put made a tender profile for him
then they took a girl that was morbidly
obese like 300 pounds not attractive at
all but made a profile for her she had
almost 500 matches the guy only had a
little over 100 in a 24-hour period in a
major city so that tells you right there
and then that for men even if you're a
top tier guy top tier men don't get the
same amount of options as below average
women and you gotta hope they show up
for the date that they even like you
because you know all that comes into
play because once again you might be a
cool guy to her but you might turn off
by how you speak how you are and that's
actually got to include as well here's
the difference between men and women
when it comes to dating when a guy goes
on a date with a girl he's looking for a
reason to qualify her uh you know what
she's kind of fat but she's nice uh you
know what I don't like her hair but you
know what she seems really cool or I
like her shoes like guys go on a date
looking for a reason to qualify the girl
right when girls go on dates or when
girls talk to men they're looking for a
reason to disqualify you and it could be
the smallest thing oh his shoes don't
match oh I don't like his belt oh he
sounds kind of weird like girls are
looking to disqualify men because they
have so many options versus men don't
have as many options so they're looking
to qualify any girl I think a lot of it
is really just confidence I think that's
really what it comes down to is getting
experience going to the gym being the
best version of yourself of course yeah
uh but I feel like a lot of people just
kind of get stuck where they feel like
even if they do that they're still not
going to be attractive but imagine
Graham yes the guy that's raised by a
single mom right he has no one to look
up to he's going through school it sucks
he's depressed like that guy has no hope
unless he has a change of person that he
meets for example or he sees a YouTube
video changes his life the guy's stuck
so unfortunately most people are in that
box and we also live in a gynocentric
society where we push the female
experience over the male experience we
tell men to you know be more feminine be
nice get in touch with your feelings and
all those other you know soft stuff and
the reality is that men need to be more
masculine now than ever before but the
thing is is that see we live in a
society right where we lie to men and
tell them get in touch with your
feelings be nice be soft Etc girls even
say this oh open up to me but the
reality is they want a guy that's
traditionally masculine strong and stoic
women don't want guys that are feminine
and emotional like them but see I feel
like as long as you
pick a lane and you stick with it and
you're congruent with that and you
believe in that people are drawn to that
because you are your true self whether
that's a little bit more feminine more
masculine somewhere in the middle if you
pick something you're like this is who I
am take it or leave it congruency
confidence and that unwavering ability
to say this is who I am that's a
masculine trait though being congruent
sticking to your guns is a masculine
trick but couldn't you say even if
you're more feminine that maybe that's
that airs more on that side of that oh
then you'd be congruent by yourself
the girls wouldn't accept that so like
yeah so like women don't so the thing is
is that girls will sit there and say get
in touch with your feelings and be more
feminine whatever but the reality is
that they're not attracted to that what
we've come to learn because we've
interviewed over 2 000 women on our
channel right we've looked at studies
we've talked to thousands of men no one
has spoken more of modern day women than
we have in the west what I've come to
realize this alarming
Discovery is that women will say one
thing but actually do something else or
respond completely differently to things
that were that are unconventional that
guys typically don't think is attractive
for example a girl will say I like nice
guys but the reality is she's chasing
the guy that doesn't call her back that
doesn't sit there and negotiate with her
and doesn't give her attention but the
guy that gives her all the attention
takes her on four dates gives her
flowers treats you like a princess same
with a guy a guy most men would Trace
would would go after the woman who's not
calling them back who's playing hard to
get who's saying you know I think most
guys would be happy to get anything they
don't even get they don't even have the
options but between the two if you have
someone who's calling you all the time
who's always wanted to hang out versus
someone else who's maybe like having
their own life they're doing their own
things they're not calling you back all
the time I think that's just a human
trait no it's it's definitely more
female and the reason why it's more
females because women have way more
options for men right if a girl's
calling you all the time being annoying
that's one thing but most guys don't
even have that experience like only a
small percentage men are in a position
where they're able to filter out women
like that you're calling me too much get
out of here that's a smart percentage of
guys most guys can't even get a date
most guys can't even talk to a girl it
is so bad that like guys resorting to
like sex robots and like think about it
the whole only Fan's economy is built
off of men while getting sex why is that
it's the current market that we live in
and as well most guys know it is bro
they want a girl but they don't know how
to get a girl so what did they do jerk
off go watch a sex movie It's just sad
bro yeah I feel like a lot of people get
to a point of that where eventually they
get tired and that's when they make a
change there's there's got to be some
Catalyst for them to to want to make a
change from what from watching porn or
no not necessarily watching porn I think
it's more so of of
being unhappy with your current life and
wanting to make a change oh yeah and
seeing an outcome of that of course of
course you have to find a way out though
yeah and but most people can't find a
way because they don't know how to yeah
well I think I think a lot of that just
comes down to just discipline and and
pushing yourself outside of your comfort
zone of course of course but yeah but in
different Endeavors right so like like I
would say like you know pushing yourself
out of your comfort zone a lot of times
is being able to tell girls no holding
women accountable we live in a society
where girls honestly aren't held
accountable a lot of the time they're
not told no they're not told that this
is unacceptable Behavior right we got
girls out here that want to have a
boyfriend at home that's going to be
strong and masculine and dutiful but at
the same time they want to be able to go
to the girls night out and club and you
know talk to other men and get other
phone numbers and still be able to court
their options and I look at it like no
that's unacceptable Behavior but if I
say that they look at like that's
misogynistic no that's just having
boundaries and respecting yourself why
are you giving a relationship to a girl
it wants to behave like she's single
it's weird because I have not had that
experience of of having to like you know
say hey honey don't go out tonight or
yeah it's it's maybe I gravitate towards
people who naturally are inclined to
stay home well also you gotta remember
you know multi-manner yeah but no status
I didn't I didn't always used to be like
that I mean I was grinding at like 18
years old but nothing and even
throughout High School I mean I'm like
five foot three not the tallest guy
everyone I've dated has been taller than
me yeah what do you have though ambition
she saw you going somewhere in places in
life high school maybe I mean I was
playing the drums I mean that's really
what I had going for me I was playing
the drums
there are qualifiers for anybody and I
think really when it comes down to it I
honestly probably would put confidence
at the utmost like the most important
thing if you're trying to find a mate I
would say it would be confident but it
was it was never the money though
because I remember even being 21 I had
just bought my first property could not
get a date every date it would go on and
I'd be swiping online I think I was on
like Okay Cupid I was desperate yeah and
you want to go on a date with me the few
dates I did go on instant friend zone
instant but I would go in I was nervous
as unsure of myself and even that was me
I think making a hundred and something
thousand a year I just bought my first
property I got a lot of things going for
me even the ambition that you talked
about right but I couldn't
for some reason get myself out of my
head of just like does she like me it's
just it I and I feel like that once I
got out of my head on that it really
just embraced this is who I am that's
when things really started to change
well confidence is important but you
have to have other things in place too I
always say if anything you need to get
respect from your girl first that that
is a foundation from which everything
will be built because if your girl
doesn't respect you she cannot love you
I would say if you're if you're defining
it as a generally like a a general
guiding principle I would say everything
so far yeah it would make I think a lot
is just having boundaries but I feel
like it goes both ways doesn't it like
for women I feel like they need to have
a standard that I think their partner
should hold on to as should demand for
the woman oh here's the problem though
here's the problem women standards are
celebrated men's standards are
discriminate or made fun of right so
like if a guy says I don't want to
promiscuous woman I don't want a girl
that's fat I don't want a girl that's
rude that's annoying that's crass that's
considered insecure but if a guy if a
girl says I want a man that's taller
than me makes me more money than me
successful ambitious you go girl you
know you're worth you go Queen the
problem is that male boundaries are
disrespected female boundaries are
totally respected and encouraged and
even if a girl doesn't let's say a
girl's fat obnoxious and rude and quite
frankly doesn't deserve the caliber of
man that she thinks she deserves Society
will still prop her up and tell her you
deserve that multi-millionaire six foot
six foot three guy but even though
you're ugly but let's just say that is
what's wrong with that if with what if
she feels like she's entitled to that
what what does that do what negative
outcome does that have well the problem
with that is that number one she feels
entitled when she hasn't earned it and
then number two is that that sets her up
for long-term failure because the reason
why so many girls are perpetually single
is because they overestimate their
sexual market value and what I mean by
sexual market value is their looks they
think they qualify for a guy that's an
eight or a nine top tier guy when there
are five and the reason why they think
that is because the amount of match with
one of these guys on Tinder they might
have slept with one of these guys on a
drunken hookup or they might have went
out on a coffee there with one but the
reality is you were able to attract that
guy but can you retain that guy and
that's where many modern day women fail
they're not able to retain these Caliber
men they can just get social sexual
situation with them and nothing else but
then they think okay I deserve this
caliber of guy I'm not settling or if
they do it settle they treat the guy
that's actually on their level very
poorly because they think they deserve
more so this delusion ends up not only
affecting their ability to find a guy
but ends up hurting the guy that ends up
selling it doesn't feel like it's 50
fault for both sides it's also the guy's
fault it is for not setting boundaries
yes for accepting but it goes back to
what I said men don't set boundaries
because they're shame for doing
something if I say if I I can get cancer
for saying a girl is fat and rude I can
literally they'll be like oh taking this
down off Tick Tock that's hate speech
that's misogynistic but if a girl says
small dick energy I'm not dating a short
guy completely no one bats an eye men
can't have standards but women can
let's pushing I'll go yeah I mean
I'm a short guy yeah I understand that
I'm not going to be everyone's cup of
tea yeah of course but my thought is
that you know out of seven billion
people there's enough of a percentage
that would be into what I have to offer
for sure and obviously you've been able
to amplify that by you know creating a
great platform you know making yourself
very financially successful Etc but the
point I'm trying to make is that a girl
can go on the internet and make fun of
you for being short and say you're a
loser and you have small dick energy but
if you went ahead and you said well
you're a fat you're gonna get
canceled but I feel like guys say that
all the time online and they get
canceled no but defensive it depends on
who we're dying if we're talking about
random people online I feel like they
already say that and here's the other
thing a girl can make fun of a guy for
being short he can't control that right
but if a dude makes fun of a girl for
being fat she can absolutely control
that but we sit here and say love your
curves you go girl Queen but if a guy is
short uh well small dick energy short
dude you can't control that I don't know
I feel like you almost have an advantage
now being short because you could really
exemplify other qualities and people
look at you for sure differently so I
feel like you could always play to his
strength optimistic yeah you're
optimistic yeah most guys and here's the
other thing too like what I'm basically
trying to demonstrate here is that
female standards are always celebrated
male standards are always disrespected
and looked at as discrimination why do
you feel like it's that way well men
can't speak openly about what they want
like you said before men need to have
boundaries right sure what I'm saying is
that's the reason why so many men don't
have boundaries is because it's
Politically Incorrect and socially
unacceptable for meant to have
boundaries I'll give an example if I
tell guys
yo you have a girlfriend she needs to
respect you she shouldn't be at the club
you know shaking booty and hanging out
with their girlfriends and going to
Miami for girls trips they'll sit there
and tell me that I'm insecure they'll
say oh what's wrong with you what are
you so insecure about no it's just
common respect that you have a man at
home why are you putting yourself in
precarious situations that could hurt
the relationship right but
um but on the other end right like girls
are totally like if a girl says I want
this caliber of man I want this whatever
even if she doesn't qualify for it so
sign will prop her up and tell her you
deserve that man like no one ever tells
women no but we definitely tell men No
so at what point though does trust
factor into that like let's say for
friends getting married or I don't know
her friends celebrating a birthday yeah
there's 15 of her friends going out she
wants to join yeah at what point does
trust play into that where it's like you
don't want to tell them no don't go and
hang out with your friends because
you're going to a club I mean to me that
just seems like well I was I was I say
you you can't control a girl you
obviously can't do that so you're gonna
stay inside the only thing you could
control is what you do and how you
respond you want to go cool you're
single when you come back but but
there's got to be a line here right but
yeah that's not manipulation at all but
but let's tell me boundaries and not
acting on that example
hold on let me give my example sure go
ahead uh one year relationship she's
going out with her friends celebrating a
birthday party sure thing 15 girls are
gonna be there she's known forever you
would tell her no you can't go to that
because you're going to a club I would
tell her you can go and do whatever you
do but you will be single when you
return but why why why does that make
sense to throw out a relationship like
that that otherwise is good because if
she respects you she wouldn't have went
in the first place but that seems like
more like an ultimatum that you're
placing on it's not ultimatum she has a
choice to make okay but that's an
ultimatum no no it's like no no she
could do it she's completely free to do
whatever she wants because the thing is
is that she's putting the she's putting
the relationship in a risky situation
why why would she be don't you would you
trust me because let's be honest here
what are nightclubs for well here's the
thing so I will say in general oh okay
in general yeah nightclubs are for
meeting other people okay all that sort
of stuff I get that but I've also seen
just as many innocent encounters where
women want to go to both dance with
their friends have a great time
and I don't see the issue with that I
think it really depends on the context I
think it depends on context as well like
if it's all of her friends and they're
like hey it's you know so-and-so's
birthday you should come and it's a
really close friends of those birthday
it's like you're not gonna tell the like
oh sure it's not an ultimatum but
effectively it is right you can't set
that on on your well I suppose you could
right on your girl though and and expect
that like I don't know it's it's her
friends right unless if she was leading
the charge and she was like everyone
let's go to the nightclub and she
invites all of her friends but she
doesn't invite you that might be a
little bit different but you have to
have some compassion for her because you
also understand that she has a Duty or a
diligence to her friends in the same way
that she does to you remember we
mentioned earlier right about there
being bad people in the world right and
you don't really know who the person is
like being bad so for example in that
environment there's bad people now she
might be an angel she might be perfect
or friends may be like yo Laquisha don't
worry about your man at home just have
fun tonight we're all lit we're all
drunk and that one encounter of that one
bad friend spoil the whole group I'm
just saying the environment there can be
tainted now is it gonna happen who knows
we're just saying if you have a man at
home why people in that situation why
it's it's not a good look like you're
going to be in an area where there's a
bunch of thirsty men offering your girl
liquor trying to dance with her and put
them and it puts the girl in a bad
position here's the other thing too she
could get drunk and something could
happen and then next thing you know bam
like she's
yo boyfriend we didn't even know it's
like legit bro funny bachelorette
parties bro oh my gosh yeah a bunch of
girls oh they're just chilling by
themselves before there's a gang of guys
in there in their room and I'm just
saying bro things happen so don't be
dumb about it be smart here's the thing
here's the thing I refuse to give a
woman the comfort of security with me as
her boyfriend while she can
simultaneously and behave as though
she's single I have boundaries and
standards and this is what it comes with
it because the thing is is that if a
girl truly respects you she's not going
to want to go to the club she's not
going to want to be around her friends
that want to go ahead and do all this
extra stuff because yeah like like she's
not going to want to behave like she's
single when she's with a man that she
actually admires and respects and my
thing is if she wants to go to Club
that's cool but you no longer are in a
relationship with me because I'm not
going to look stupid sitting at home
while you go out and behave like you're
single that's this is the first point I
actually would say I have a pretty
strong disagreement fair enough look if
you trust your partner and you trust
their friends because also it's you your
due diligence as your you know your
partner's partner to get to know her
friends and to understand who she likes
hanging out with because she probably
wants that too and if you can trust
everybody and they're all going out to
the club and she wants to have a good
time I feel like there's nothing wrong
with that but if you set this not
ultimatum but if you make this apparent
and it's a boundary at this boundary
apparent in the beginning of the
relationship such as hey if we're dating
I don't want you going to the club it
makes me uncomfortable uh would you do
me the respect of not going to the club
I think that's fine because that's just
a preference at that point right and I
think all preferences are probably you
ever been to a club yeah website Club
yeah
people dance well
drink
what does that lead to dancing and
drinking sex that is one of the
potential outcomes but that that's not a
one-to-one ratio it's not like you just
so here's the thing I did it here's I
think this is where I disconnected you
can dance and do that this is where the
disconnect is disconnect is this I think
you guys grossly underestimate like how
easy it is for women to get sex and
since it's easy for women to get sex a
threshold for them to cheat is also
easier as well it's a slightest scale
that works together like for men it's
very difficult to get sex doesn't mean
they always want sex though because it's
always available it doesn't mean they're
going to take it but here's my thing
yeah I look at it if your girl is out
dressed provocatively and seeking
attention that is cheating and some
people might look at me like whoa what
do you mean it's because men and women
are different a man has to actually go
out there put his nuts on the line talk
to a girl to initiate some type of
interaction women don't do that women
rarely if ever approach men how do they
do it they do it by exposing their
sexuality men show their Charisma women
show their bodies how would that be any
different from a guy driving down with
like you know a Bentley convertible with
a nice watch on because you still got to
put in work you still have to put in
work to get that girl even though the
Bentley and the watch all it does it
gives you another 20 seconds to to that
is to build attraction if anything like
it's still very difficult as a man even
let's say you got a Bentley and a nice
watch and everything else like that a
girl will still curb you like but a girl
on the other hand she could go into a
club going ah and dudes will still smash
her but if you go into the club you
gonna go to jail you know what I mean
like it's not the same thing if you do
that with confidence you walk it through
yeah I do they're gonna be like yeah
oh
because that is who you are but the
thing is is that so people hate this but
the reality is there is a double
standard men and women are not the same
there's behaviors that are completely
unacceptable for women and there's
behaviors that are completely
unacceptable for men and that's okay and
my thing is is that women get mad at
double standards that don't benefit them
that's where they complain about I look
at it if you're in a relationship with a
man you like that man Etc and he tells
you hey these are my boundaries and you
want to go out to the club with your
girls and behave like you're single cool
you are effectively single at that point
and that man reserves the right to walk
away from you and I think he should
because as a self-respecting man that's
providing a relationship and security to
that woman it's extremely disrespectful
for her to put herself in a precarious
situation so the relationship she can't
also provide her own security like she
can also have a job have her own money
and okay that sounds great on paper
right but so does communism here's the
problem
now we're getting into the feminism
topic all right women even when they
make their own money and can provide
their own security they still want a man
that makes on average about 56 percent
more than they do women don't seek their
equals most of the time bare minimum
they seek their equal they want men that
are better than them in almost every
regard height income strength competence
confidence all these things because
women look for security long term men
don't care about these things so if a
girl is able to create her own security
that's great but that's not something
that men really care about
I I do want to bring it back to this
club discussion we should revisit that
sure do you think that it could be
rooted in some form of insecurity not
allowing your girl to go to the club
because for me personally if if I was
dating a girl and I truly I I believed
her and I thought that there was trust
between us I really couldn't care less
as long as she's safe and I know that
she will be physically safe she can go
and do as she pleases you ever seen your
girlfriend's phone or a girl's phone no
I'm just saying right bro like people
you can trust to a certain extent but
environments you can't trust because for
example it might not be here it could be
your friend it could be somebody else
yeah it could be for example her ideal
type of guy oh my God that's like uh Dez
Bryant you don't know who's in there
it's like why be in that scenario we
don't know what's gonna happen and like
but I feel like that's life though it's
like every scenario you don't know
what's gonna happen no I don't think I
need control over every single aspect of
my life about mitigating risks though
but the thing is the risk is already so
mitigated and on top of that there's a
risk of just thinking someone else's
life is kind of your own when you put
this ultimatum on them that's just not
it no no it's just what you're wanting
to tolerant what you're not willing to
tolerate to me it feels like a lot of
wasted energy on somebody else and you
could be focusing that on yourself
better yeah yeah just like thinking of
this like what's in her phone what is
she doing well he just used that as an
example so you guys understand like what
like kind of like what a girl's phone is
like but right it's not and security
it's here's the thing it's Security in
knowing that a woman is a woman women
are emotional creatures their actions
are dictated by how they feel at the
moment and the time okay so if they're
with their friends they're drinking
their friends want to go ahead let's go
talk to those guys they're cute blah
blah blah that one thing could lead to
another and the thing like I said before
the threshold for cheating for a woman
is far less than that of a man I look at
it if you're gonna dress provocatively
talk to other men kiss another guy dance
another guy that's all extremely
disrespectful behavior that constitutes
this cheating yeah I don't think you
should kiss other people and I will but
say hey like you're opening the door for
it I'm gonna give you one they're gonna
go to the club so I'm in Miami I have a
lot of celebrity friends right
this celebrity is always a Miami
partying so one night we're out at this
club Vendo and
we're in our section just vibing having
a good time goes like Oh my God I'll
come to section whatever there's a bunch
of these bunch of white girls from
California right they're here in Miami
the party have fun I think it's
somebody's birthday and at least five of
them have boyfriends so they come to
section they get drinks whatever they're
chilling and we're just talking right so
some of our boyfriends like you have a
boyfriend whatever we're just coolness
we leave the club go back to their house
bro I guarantee you I kid you not bro
look who's our boyfriends what did it
what are they actually doing at the
house yeah you're doing the worst and
some of them but slept with dogs
I'm just saying this happens it is
possible I'm not saying it's of course
that's possible anything else we can
walk outside of the door and get struck
by lightning as possible I see that to
say it's not the ultimately it's
possible so if it's possible to happen
if it really cares about you she'll not
be an antibiant at all so you know what
I have to go on my man's home I'm
leaving with her to stay at an
environment bro that's the Spectrum
here's the thing that's also a small
percentage no yeah I mean I thought
we're like maybe five percent I mean
what would you say out of a of the of
cheating or of yeah but both of cheating
and and women that would put themselves
in that scenario well the new studies
now show that women cheat more than men
50 of married women have a backup guy
here's the thing guys we teach guys to
mitigate risk when men get in
relationships with women they take on
far more risk than a woman does we live
in a world now where if you get married
to a girl she can clean you out take you
on alimony child support you lose the
marital home Etc guys take way more risk
when they get in long-term relationships
with women so I tell guys we live in a
society where women are encouraged to be
hoes to be promiscuous excise their
options to go ahead and get the best guy
that they can get to date multiple men
at the same time they're encouraged to
have all these bad habits that are not
conducive to good long-term
relationships so the only way that you
can combat this through feminism and all
everything else that's going on in the
modern day world is you need to be very
strong on your principle and very strong
on your frame when a girl's with a man
that she loves admires and respects and
knows that this guy will leave her if
she does some stuff like that that in
itself is the power where the girl's not
gonna say Okay I want to go to the club
or whatever because she knows better she
knows I'm with a winner I don't want to
um put myself in a situation where I can
effectively be single by going out to
the club with this guy you need your
girl to be more scared of losing you
than you are of losing her and that's
where I want guys to be I want them to
be in a situation where the girl likes
them more than they like the girl and I
know that sounds evil but the reason why
is because that's the only way you're
going to combat the amount of options
that women have the bad habits that
modern day women have and practice with
the you know dating multiple guys being
promiscuous Etc you need to have the
girl like you more than you like her
because that puts you in an authority
role a leadership role makes you the
dominant in the relationship and it will
have her be loyal to you respects
because quite frankly the only thing
that women the main thing that men care
about when it comes to women is loyalty
yeah that's really what we care about
women on the other hand tall money
charismatic Charming confidence is you
dress well they smell well men all we
want be pretty
be loyal and she might like you but does
respect you that's huge bro and what do
you think the difference is between that
how do you what would you call respect
because we know boundaries she follows
them bam she likes you should do
whatever she wants that right there
tells you really cares about you and
that guys for most guys like you know
what she likes me she doesn't respect me
yeah that goes along here's the other
thing too the reality is and this is why
our podcast is so popular nowadays most
guys don't have the balls to tell their
girl hey I don't commit to girls that
like to go to the club I don't commit to
girls I like to go on girls trips Etc
most guys are happy with whatever they
can get so they'll tolerate disrespect
they'll tolerate bad behavior they'll
tolerate crass attitude disrespect in
front of their friends beginning cursed
out even attack sometimes because the
need for getting laid is that strong
where they'll tolerate female bad
behavior all the time so I tell guys
you need to be on point and not tolerate
that bad behavior because it will make
your life miserable yeah what yeah do
you see on the men's side
being bombs and losers and not and not
having frame not being an authority in
the relationship and not being willing
to tell women what you like and what you
don't like because most guys would
prefer their girl not to be in the club
however they can't tell her that because
their sexual market value isn't high
enough to dictate those terms so they
can't tell a girl anything because they
got the Girl by The Skin of Their Teeth
so how are you going to tell her hey I
don't commit to girls that go to the
club you should be lucky I'm here and
that's the problem and if you're a guy
right that doesn't want to succeed in
life become better you're selfish
because once again let's see we want to
get a family right if you're not your
best version of yourself that means
you're going to suffer so I want to say
honestly speaking like if you're a guy
that wants to succeed in life you need
to improve most guys what do they want
to do play video games smoke weed relax
and that leads to what nothing so it's
just sad man it's really sad so I think
guys really need to be willing to have
boundaries and enforce them and and a
lot of guys don't have boundaries and
worse yet they don't enforce them I
agree I think boundary is important and
I think obviously enforcing boundary is
important because what would a boundary
be if it wasn't enforced yeah but at the
same time I think like look providing
that not an ultimatum oh the club exam
yeah I think if you go if you go to the
beginning of the relationship and you
establish the boundaries and you set
precedent and everything I think that's
lovely I think anyone can do whatever
that's all you got to do it they want
yeah okay yeah it's not like you're
gonna drop this on her a year later and
be like oh yeah by the way you can't go
to the club no she knows when she first
meets you what type of guy you work
because here's the thing guys women know
what kind of guys they could play with
and what guys they can't play with facts
okay they size you up when they meet you
oh this guy's kind of a pushover I could
get away with this oh this guy I can't
do get away with this he's going to
leave me you need to be that guy that's
the latter if I do some BS he's going to
leave me because as a man that's your
only Power in 2023 women have all the
leverage when it comes to dating
nowadays but they still want
relationships they still want to be with
that guy you need to become that guy and
let them know this relationship is
contingent upon your behavior I will not
tolerate BS from you and if you if you
do I will go ahead and replace you with
another girl and this more controversial
topic that's why I think I should have
multiple girlfriends monogamy is not in
your best interest as a man
what what led you to believe that well
what I've come to realize look at all
guys that are in marriages this is this
is
um human human evolution women respect
men that have social proof and women
respect men that can replace them so if
you have other women the girls that you
have will behave better because they
know that they can be replaced at any
time but couldn't you also say that you
don't need more girlfriends or wives to
to accomplish that that if you are
go to what you do you have passion
you're funny confidence like all of
these things are qualities that you
could you know find someone else if you
if you that's true but it's sometimes
you got to give girls a reminder
and that's and the reason why I say that
is because
she has a constant reminder of her value
with Instagram with guys hitting on her
with the internet Etc so you kind of
have to like go coming back to that
thing where she needs to like you more
than you like her unfortunately for us
as human beings I wish it wasn't like
this guys by the way I really wish it
wasn't like this but I've done so much
study on this and I figured this out
women want men
that other women want to be with right
and other men want to be that's just how
it is you go into any nightclub where
all the girls concentrated in the VIP
sections with the guys a minority of men
are having sex with the majority of the
women women look for the same traits and
Men typically regardless of how they say
that they're special so my thing is if
you have other girls that is a very
honest indicator that you are attractive
and if a girl sees you with other women
and she sees that you're attractive
she's going to respect you and she's
going to want to fight for you even more
so when she knows that there's
competition it's human nature look you
don't have to cheat we're just saying in
fact you can attract other girls is very
important yeah yeah I mean I think you
should have multiple girls as a guy so
that girls don't get comfortable but
that's my way on it you could do it
maybe where you might flirt with another
girl or maybe she's like damn this guy
or maybe you make yourself available
foreign to me because that's not
something I could ever do I just I
couldn't everyone's different about it
yeah but what I've realized is when I
have multiple girls the girls that I
have behave way better because they know
that they can be replaced versus when I
have just one girl she starts to get
comfortable disrespect can happen it's
cetera now can you do in other ways
maybe you're not as available all the
time her mind is racing you know I've
always had a woman's imagination is your
best friend as a man right but there's
nothing more solid than her seeing you
with other girls knowing that damn okay
this guy is it and the way women May
select is the way women May select is
based on doubt do I have the best guy
that I can get and if she feels like she
has the best guy that she can get bam
she's gonna turn off that radar looking
for other guys and you win but the way
that she needs to see that a lot of the
times is by through other women women
are very strong social creatures right
if we all go to a club right and let's
say Graham sees a hot girl right he's
like hey guys uh chick is hot I'm
leaving we ain't gonna be like oh what
are you doing but he's not he doesn't
need our opinion he's just gonna go
leave her she's hot he likes her cool
women however they're not like that they
meet a guy at the club they're gonna go
to the bathroom they're gonna have their
powwow oh I met this guy what do you
think he's here's this scram what do you
think blah blah blah they're gonna need
a co-sign from the other girls but let's
say you were in the club and you had two
girls with you and then you talked to
her well she's not gonna need to consult
with her friends to the same level
because she already saw you with women
so she knows off RIP by you being with
other women okay he's not a creeper he's
not a serial killer he's not a weirdo
these beautiful women have signed off on
him so he's doing something right this
is why men that have women men that have
sex a lot of girls are respected versus
on the other side you see a girl with a
bunch of dudes you're like oh what the
hell for example Dan Bilzerian yeah you
know that's why guys respect him because
he has a bunch of chicks around them but
when a girl has a bunch of dudes there's
like what is this is porno I'm good I
don't want to be around this so women
respect men that have other uh women
because it's a sign of social proof and
status I think you're talking about a
really unique contingent of people also
in like that Miami life here in Las
Vegas and when I was living in Southern
California that was not my my experience
in the dating scene I think for the most
part two people in like I said in my
experience and through my friends and my
friends that are girls as well like you
kind of just want a one-on-one
relationships that's that's what most
people just desire that's what fulfilled
people the most is what made them the
most happy now how much upbringing plays
into this because I feel like in like
like what Jack was saying a lot of upper
like in in your area is very much like
family oriented yeah
um nothing crazy I know Miami would be
the exact opposite I grew up with two
parents they were married together did
you guys grow up with yep I grew up in a
two-parent household Muslim household
parents are still together and I saw
them and I was like okay this looks like
you guys look super happy and that's
kind of like what what shaped I guess my
belief in like okay this is kind of what
I want to achieve but I want to do that
as well that we're not only in Miami for
example we travel a lot and as well we
were other places before so I get what
you're saying with the Miami clubs like
what type of environments are you going
to you're going to clubs you're going to
like Barnes and Noble I mean like
there's probably a different group of
people here's here's an uncomfortable
reality
women will share a man if he's high
value enough girls would rather share a
guy that's a winner than have a loser
all to themselves and with feminism
coming in where women earn more money
than ever before they're more educated
than ever before they have higher status
than ever before there's a dwindling
amount of men that are able to compete
for their attraction so what ends up
happening women become victims of their
own success they go up the totem pole
doors close man you go up the totem pole
doors open so women whether they want to
accept it or not are sharing the same
small percentage of men so what I'm
saying
is that I get what you're saying where
two-parent household nuclear family I
agree with that I think that's the
backbone of the United States but we're
quickly going into a society where
most men are not going to qualify for
most women yeah and most girls would
rather stay single than settle down with
a guy that's below them in their eyes
that's where we're at nowadays and if
you talk to any attractive girl in a
major city that's how a lot of them
think we've interviewed two thousand
girls from pretty much all 50 states 30
plus countries whether it's the United
States Canada England UK even even the
poorer countries like Ukraine or Romania
whatever women still want to gravitate
towards the highest status men
it's just the way just just the way they
may select so the days of being an
average guy and being able to find a
girl it's getting tougher and tougher
for the average guy see I just don't
have enough data like yeah yeah this is
so beyond yeah I know I'm like I'm used
to or like accustomed to or what I've
seen so I can't comment because it's
like it's it's so far out of what I've
experienced yes right understandable
understandable and and for people that
like and I've noticed that like people
that aren't like in a dating scene right
now or have been haven't haven't uh been
in a relationship for a long time and
they're just kind of getting back into
it like a lot of these things I say
shock them they're like what the hell
like is it really changed that much and
I talk about this in a book extensively
like how the dating Marketplace has
changed drastically thanks to feminism
thanks to the Internet thanks to
Instagram thanks to social media in
general like
things have changed where it's made it a
lot more difficult for a guy to get a
date and even in the past five years has
changed drastically how so what way
um making it harder for guys yeah well
now
you have only fans
you have twitch
you have uh Instagram Tick Tock how does
it make it harder because as a man
you're competing right
with all these other guys that are
giving her attention access
so so women what happens is this a girl
has a social media following right even
an average girl two thousand five
thousand ten thousand followers she now
thinks that she qualifies for the top
tier guys because she has somewhat of a
social media following or people are
hitting her up on the Internet so again
she thinks that her value is higher than
what it really is because the internet
constantly reaffirms that and tells her
oh my God you're so beautiful look at
any I take an experiment
if you guys have any female friends
which I hope you don't but if you do go
ahead ask her can I see your phone look
at her Instagram DMS look at her text
messages you guys are gonna see like I
think one of the biggest things that
like awares guys on like how many
options girls have look at a girl's
phone man and you guys will see what I'm
talking about those aren't necessarily
the the DM she wants to get or like
exactly you're right but what is it
numbers in her head you know what I'm
attractive like all these guys gonna be
up I'm hot that leads to what her saying
you know what yeah but that's like you
know the creepy guy like in the corner
of the bar coming up to him be like hey
I think you're pretty but she's still
getting validated though but then
there's one or two that are blue checked
her out she's celebrities that hit her
up is like whoa this this is me I did
this oh I'm amazing I'm special
like I'm telling you bro it does
something to their psyche where because
women are naturally solipsistic right
studies show this and they're thinking
the world revolves around them and
naturally narcissistic because beauty is
their main agency so you take someone
that's naturally solipsistic naturally
narcissistic and you give them the
amplifier of social media and the
internet and attention from random dudes
all over the world telling them they're
beautiful beautiful and they're Queens
no matter how they behave bro that's a
recipe for disaster look at what they
post why would they post that attention
I don't know see I look at it from a
very logical standpoint of you know
anything for the algorithm and I think
if they want to grow their five like I
don't know 99 of these girls don't
monetize yeah no but they don't make
money why would they do that what's the
bottom line of it it's attention
attention like let's do the same thing
they'll post pictures of the cars
watches like I I see the same thing
guys oh my God I love your car it's like
you are bro I'm a car head yeah it's
different if you post your body as a guy
in the gym you're gonna get a bunch of
dudes hey you looking slow bro yeah but
but that's a but that's a similar ego
boost of you feeling better about
yourself other you get other people's
approval rather whether it's male or
female doesn't that have a similar not
to the same degree as a dude right let's
say you got a top-tier Instagram you've
private jets and all this other stuff
right you got to talk to your Instagram
you're still not going to get a fraction
of the attention as an average chick
and here's the difference you had to
earn that car you had to earn that watch
you had to earn that ability she takes a
random pick on the beach with a bikini
and they're like 10K
what's your cash app what someone could
have inherited the money they could have
they could have won something I mean
there's a whole bunch of scenarios too
where someone would have money
but beauty is far more common the beauty
is far more common than guys that
inherit money let's be honest I think a
lot of beauty is just in the it's corny
yeah in a way I mean some sometimes it's
just like but you are drawn to a certain
person over another but as a guy like I
said earlier let's smash anything yeah
girls can get any man they want yeah men
can only get what they can yeah there's
a saying girls get who they want make it
who they can
in a nutshell it's it I'm telling y'all
man I go into detail about this in my
book by the way why women deserve less
I'll read it bro uh but I talk about it
because like so many guys like will sit
there and give a girl money they'll give
her attention they'll give her likes
they'll give her all this stuff and she
never liked them in the first place okay
I got a uh sure random question on the
philosophy of all of this sure from a
casual I wouldn't even call myself a
casual viewer but someone who obviously
sees the title of this book why women
deserve less yeah
oh and hardcover as well
exactly and audio coming Auto audible
coming soon the general uh idea of this
conversation yeah I could see a lot of
people hearing what you guys are saying
yeah and developing some sort and
although maybe they're not heeding what
you're saying like to the T of incel
type Behavior oh man I really could see
those can we go no no no I'm not doing
this just to be a contrarian I'm just
saying when you nearly solely at least
on this post podcast yeah talk about
like how women are being propped up and
how men are the ones that like you gotta
grind you gotta work and they just get
it handed to them and stuff like that
like how is that supposed to it doesn't
seem encouraging it seems more just like
oh look at this poor hand that we were
dealt and boom like you know like it
doesn't sound like you're propping them
up propping men up yes no we're giving
them the uncomfortable realities that no
one gives a about you you're a man
you have to go out there and earn your
value but understand that women are
given their value and we don't play the
same game
do you think that that has that will
yield better results absolutely than
coming from a place of like look sure
maybe this is the way that it is but at
the same time this means that it's your
time to go and be badass like work out
get strong I talk about that in the book
I talk about like how you have to
prioritize yourself you got to get in
the gym make your money become the man
right and then the girls will be a
byproduct but the problem is that guys
think I can be mediocre and still get a
girl but yeah but I think it's some of
that though you could still have a great
job have passion be who you are and then
go on a date instantly get friend zoned
because you don't have that Charisma you
don't have that tension you don't know
how to talk to them so I think a lot of
that is really just practice yeah that
too and socializing that's why we say
you got to go on multiple dates and deal
with a lot of girls I have a rule I tell
guys don't get married until you're 35
making six figures a year six months of
one year Savings in shape going to the
gym consistently and having sex with 50
girls 50 50. yeah that sounds like too
much work 50. and and listen
you could be spending that doing
something that that will better your own
life right so you got to get all those
other things in place too but filling to
you but whatever the heck you want
right you said that's a lot of time it's
not it's not really I'll tell you why
yeah it's something you spend working on
yourself and figuring out what women
actually want and what their nature is
you can save you money and time in the
future let's say for example you spend
your whole life on business your career
right yeah that's all you know you find
a woman it's attractive you like her you
marry her guess what you're not knowing
about female nature I hope women can be
or what women actually want you're
giving all these stuff you're kind of
spoiling her she's like you know what oh
I don't buy him anymore I'm Gonna Leave
she cheats on you divorces you think
I'll have your stuff but if you knew a
woman were from the very beginning he
had experience oh you know what she's
actually not a good person she actually
wants to use me for my money I don't
want her let me tell you where the 50
girl thing came from wouldn't you sift
that out though in the beginning you
can't because you don't know here so let
me break this down for you this is why I
said 50 girls yeah
by the time a girl hits puberty she's
getting hit on by guys constantly
whether it's kids at middle school high
school the weird teacher at a party
somewhere when she goes off to college
Etc women have thousands of interactions
with opposite gender guess what happens
that's a lot of practice they get a lot
of practice and figure out which guys
are cool which guys are weird this dude
has this weird tick this guy has money
but he's lame Etc women become black
belts experts at Discerning male value
men however don't get nearly as much
practice because you actually have to go
up to her you know formulate some kind
of sentence come up with some pickup
line Etc most guys don't get the Reps in
that they need to women however get all
the Reps in right and in today's society
not only do girls get the Reps in right
through social media guys coming up to
them whatever they're also encouraged to
exercise their options to date a lot of
guys women nowadays are more promiscuous
than ever before so as a man how are you
going to be able to go out there and
pick a girl that's marriage material and
or girlfriend material for a serious
relationship won't know if you don't
have the same amount of reps and
practice here's the problem guys go out
with a girl the girl will behave in a
manner that she thinks the guy will like
the guy's an idiot he doesn't have
enough sexual experience hesitate enough
girls doesn't know how to tell a hell
from a housewife and he ends up
committing to this girl marries her
gives her a house Etc gets divorced
destroyed alimony paying child support
because he didn't understand how women
think and female nature they make the
Cardinal mistake of thinking that men
and women are the same and we are not
but you only get that through experience
and I say if you haven't had sex with 50
girls you're going to be decently okay
at being able to tell a girl that's
worthy of relationship which one isn't
because women have an inherent Advantage
from the amount of reps that they get
throughout their lifetime I just don't
know if it's intercourse that's like the
actual metric of like oh I understand
how women's mind works and also one more
thing no it has to intercourse and I'll
explain why it's the football okay I
wanna I wanna hear you explain why and
at the same time also if girls are
constantly receiving like guys that are
like complimenting them trying like
hitting on them or whatever like in
Middle School et cetera like you just
said wouldn't that require a guy in the
equation that's doing the exact same
thing
but it's many different men is my point
wouldn't you just grow numb to it after
a certain point like it just becomes
like a you know it kind of pings off of
you and that's the point but that's the
point they get they get practice to the
point where they're judoing guys out of
their way naturally versus you as a guy
you don't know what you're doing because
but when you talk to a girl as a guy
she's a black bat of social dynamics at
that point an 18 year old girl could
walk into a room size up the room
immediately because not only do women
have social uh superiority over men but
they're also able to detect a man's
value immediately off of how he comes
off you guys said first at the beginning
of the podcast confidence is the most
important thing you wanna know why
because when a man is confident it's a
symbolizer for accomplishments in his
life and girls look for what security
that is why confidence is so when you
peel the layers back that's why
confidence is so important but girls are
able to detect that from your tonality
the way you convey yourself body
language
Etc and girls have this experience way
more than you by the time you actually
go up to her at the party and talk to
her that's why it goes like older men
because they're more experienced than
what they're going through in life and
they know what they want intercourse to
answer his problem the two sizes the
token because the girl intercourse it
has no it has to be a guy right but okay
what you're saying like the girls they
get all this experience sizing up guys
or whatever yeah the person that they're
talking to in the first place is a guy
that's getting experience but they're
not every guy yeah and you know
it's funny the guy that she's talking to
either he's a player he's older or he
knows the game if you're saying it's
very limited selection of guys that are
getting all these small different group
of girls yes a bunch of experience yeah
they get very good at weeding out losers
because most guys are losers but the
point is that they get the experience
girls get good at weeding out losers men
never get the experience of weeding out
loser chicks because they'll take
whatever they can get because they don't
get the same experience I I don't know
for me I feel like it's it just seems
like a like an arbitrary number and I
think you can find somebody without 50.
of course can you can you can you have
20 and meet the girl of your dreams and
get married of course what I'm saying is
that generally generally speaking you're
going to be in a very good position if
you have those five things in place that
I mentioned
to get out there and get married
if you can make it happen perfect if you
want to get married in today's day and
age with all the risk going on I think
those are the minimum requirements now
is Everything 100 like let's say you
make 90k per year like can you still
yeah you know you're 10 10K off fine but
what I'm saying is that you need to have
experience with women the main or under
I've just always believed that if you
have purpose passion you do what you
love you're excited about life you have
friends you go out and socialize every
now and then I feel like that will
naturally attract people to you and then
from there as long as you have you know
the time and the resources to spend with
another person it'll happen naturally
that does help 100 and 100 that could
happen to anybody yeah we're just saying
is it likely coming that way for most
guys probably not yeah men have to do
that deliberately a lot of times these
things that you mentioned it's really
tough for a lot of guys they have to
like put it in their head and
deliberately go out and do it it's not
it's very tough to do these things
naturally yeah they have to be taught a
lot of times they've got a job that they
hate school didn't go well you know
we're just saying the average guy isn't
having that type of success being real
with you dude the average guy can barely
get a date girls flake like crazy
nowadays and we have something else it's
funny because we didn't notice either
until we coach guys who's like this is
really happening dude we were like you
we're like this came out I've been this
can't be real but it is it's sad because
the thing is is that guys like us suffer
from the Apex files you would think oh
yeah it's just it's not that hard like
yeah Girls Are Easy not man like a lot
of guys are struggling and the more I
interview girls on our show we see why
every girl it's it's crazy when I ask
girls describe your dream man six foot
plus over a hundred thousand dollars per
year yeah I want them to have a degree
all this other stuff man that's less
than one percent of the population
matches up what they want and all the
girls are chasing the same guy and worse
yet they think they deserve them but to
be fair that could be like a different
like the girls that you're having on
your podcast yeah like they're from
Miami I've seen a couple of the clips no
a lot of them from other states and
other countries everywhere bro and
different education levels
I feel like it goes the other way too
the guys are going to say who do you
want you also have a supermodel and girl
to come on the podcast in the first
place was that I'm sorry you always have
to think what kind of girl would agree
to come on the podcast the first one at
the same time we've brought a bunch of
professionals on yeah I feel like a lot
of people come on just to disagree and
here's the other thing too okay you know
what you know what's funny I love when
guys say this like or people say oh you
guys don't bring on Career women that
are smart that are educated you wanna
know what what happens when girls are
educated and make money even worse they
have even higher standards yeah and then
what about the guys you say that you see
this all the time with guys because me
and my house like because I had like I
live in a house with four other dudes
and they don't necessarily struggle to
go on dates and stuff what'd you say
pause pause man I'm just kidding don't
worry about it no but I actually have a
good time with ping-pong oh it's lovely
yeah uh but uh none of the guys usually
have he thinks it's fraus trouble like
going on on dates with girls and that's
just been my experience and all of my
friends at home like it's never been
like you just kind of either get a
dating app or you just have to have the
confidence to like it's a numbers game
you just try and try and try and then it
will work out I think it's just a lot of
practice but if you think about the guys
that you talk to when you're Consulting
those are guys that are like struggling
so you're kind of getting in a sense a
biased perspective a member
celebrity friends oh guys that are
regular guys I have friends all over I
have a full school do we deal with
and we're famous yeah exactly
nobody's safe I'm saying right now your
friends bro I guarantee you bro they do
issues of girls wait are you still in
college no oh okay I thought I was okay
I thought Graham was
yes they can get girls but are they
happy are they actually fulfilled are
they like being who they really want to
be my thing is like you can get a girl
let's see respect to you that's the big
thing like here's the thing the numbers
show it man there's more sexless men now
than ever before limits are swiping left
on Tinder 95 of the time dating after a
failure for most men most guys can't get
a girl to respond to their DM on
Instagram In fairness okay the Tinder
profiles I've seen of guys are terrible
you're right DMS absolutely right but
but again it comes back because to me
the bar is set so low that like if you
could do anything below the like
anything above the average it's like
that sets you it's two different things
it's two different things it's you got a
sliding scale on both sides so you got
guys that are mediocre right and staying
mediocre because they're watching porn
no good pictures don't understand how
women really think Etc then at the other
end women's standards are going up
because they're making more money and
getting more status so it's creating
what a bigger device between the two so
you know it is what is but a lot of guys
are struggling the data shows it man
it's it's pretty much it's it's uh
what's the word it's indisputable at
this point that a majority of men are
struggling to attract the majority of
women
and a majority of women just simply
don't like a majority of men I mean it's
got to a point now think about it the
rise of only fans the rise of girls
putting their cash apps in their
Instagram the rise of girls being able
to make money simply for posting feet
pictures this wouldn't be going on if
guys were getting late I just feel like
it's a market if people are gonna pay
for it it's a business if they're not
hurting anybody I don't see the oh well
I'm not talking about the morality of it
I'm saying that it's eve the fact that
it's even available speaks Vibe because
my argument is that guys are struggling
with women but that doesn't mean every
woman would would automatically do only
fans I think a lot of people out there
would say you know what I I envy the
money I could make but no no do that my
argument is simply that there's such a
void in men being able to meet and
attract women that women are able to
negotiate in bad faith and monetize off
of it that's what why is it bad faith I
feel like if they're providing a product
or a service and someone's willing to
pay for that service they're both
consenting I don't see that being an
issue well here's the thing they're
they're selling you a dream when you're
when you're you know we talked about
this with our friend Andrew used to run
a webcam company what you're selling to
the guy a lot of the times is attention
and the possibility of meeting the girl
and that's what the girls do is they
create this illusion they're going to
meet you one day they're gonna you're
gonna build a family you're getting this
attention so girls give you that right
without ever actually you know intending
on delivering it to you how is your
business broken down right now
so you want to talk first or about the
yeah so uh we do YouTube as you know
yeah we go live on our podcast we have
super chats we have as well ad revenue
and for example uh we have like super
thanks and donations and then we have
twitch as well we have uh Rumble and
pretty much out to rumble rumble.com
that's fresh and fit yep go support them
um and then we have as well real estate
on the side yeah and so I have 12 real
estate properties uh I've been buying
crazy the past like two years getting
you know obviously we had the interest
rates were low so it's free money yeah
so I bought I got four properties in in
Miami and then another eight in
Connecticut and I'm looking to expand so
the real estate stuff is what I do on
the side I still have my Fitness
business as well uh we do Consulting
courses we have sponsors too as well
yeah so I have another YouTube channel
called fed 1811 where I break down
criminal cases more True Crime stuff for
people that like that type of thing I do
serial killer cases terrorism Etc and I
give like my professional background in
it like I'll watch the documentary or
I'll cover a case and I'll give like a
former investigator's perspective on I
do vlogs for example our lifestyle
excited Studio we travel I have a
network called Studio Network where I
bring people millionaires from around
the world talk to our group give them
advice how to network and become
successful pretty much like that's
another revenue for me as well yeah but
yeah the podcast takes most of our time
because we six we shoot six shows a week
yeah so Monday Monday we do money Monday
where we talk about you know Finance
personal finance making money
entrepreneurship then we bring in the
girls for after hours we have all the
girls at the table the crazy stuff and
then Wednesday womanizer Wednesday teach
guys tips on how to date whatever it may
be some kind of topic right like five
signs she's cheating on you or something
like that then we'll bring the girls in
again and then Fridays either they're
calling sure something Fitness related
and then we have the show right after so
it's like daytime show and then we do
after hours which is the nighttime show
and but I will see each Show's like two
to three hours the thing the beginning
of our career we should be shot seven
days a week yeah yeah four shows a day
yeah non-stop like two two hours a per
podcast so now we do do six podcasts a
week which takes quite a bit of time and
then we got our Clips Channel as well
which that one's doing really well soon
patreon to 46 million yeah patreon and
locals
can you talk about how much it's
currently making right now are you able
to do that I suppose read the feds maybe
bro yeah
let's just say we can buy a couple
Rolexes a month there you go yeah I mean
I'm pretty transparent I make six
figures a month so I you know I uh
between my real estate property and
everything else so doing pretty well um
all the money I make I pretty much take
it and I just go buy houses with it
either
um I try not to buy houses cash I've
done it before when like a deal there
was no other way to get a deal or if
it's at the end of the year and I want
the tax benefits uh but yeah pretty much
okay most of my income that I make gets
immediately invested into uh real estate
I also have some crypto uh precious
metals and then I just started buying uh
Rolexes and APS but that I only buy
pieces that I know that are going to
hold value sure and I bought a Lambo and
I went broke yeah and you like cars yeah
I saw the svj that you have very nice
car how much can you walk us through the
finances of of buying an svj how much
was the cost can you break it down well
I think for most people you understand
first it's about trust yeah for example
those type of cars get that loan almost
impossible unless they trust you as a as
a you know as a lender yeah so what I
did was I built my relationship with
these lenders over time so I bought a
small car first and my first car was
Range Rover then I got the um McLaren by
70s and got the Evo like a Lambo truck
then I got the Rolls Royce truck then I
got the svj so that trust was built over
time which just mean to give me loans
now regarding the uh svj that's a lease
under my business and that paid I mean
I'm only payment for that every month
and that goes towards my taxes as well
so that by itself is kind of like a
business expense businessman yeah can I
ask how much the lease payment is you
really want to know I do okay first time
being set on here oh wow is exclusive I
don't share my numbers I have a reaction
to it 14k a month how much 14 km 14 000
yeah oh lee it's I still dropped my 2002
Honda
how much down how much down did you put
on that you really want to know I do
because 14 000 I thought it would be
higher to be honest with you so 50k
that's why wow he put a lot of money
down yeah yeah he's more interesting
1.2 million can you do like at least buy
it at the end of that you could are you
going to no the thing is though like for
me where I'm at
I don't keep any of my cars that long
but this car especially because like
there's only one of eight of these cars
in the color and it's different now I'll
say this though my plan was to actually
get the car have a year and sell it but
knowing the value of the car now is
going up and they're not making any more
V12 aspirated Aventador so this is the
last version that they're making
I might keep it but once again I I gotta
run the numbers more see more from that
but like right now I might keep it how
many miles do you get a month
drive a lot
um
because it can't be that many it's got
to be like 3 000 miles a year for an svj
well the thing about me I have a
relationship with the company the lender
so I could have a different lease than
most people have is this is different
yeah he has a good relationship with the
car people because it's tough to get
those cars and then especially in Miami
like there's people that want to get it
so he cut the line on a bunch of people
was able to get one because he had
bought a McLaren he had a Lamborghini
before he had like a relationship with
dealers and I pay off how many he says
or I sell them but yeah I'm still
aggressively buying up real estate I
just didn't see where you get the cash
flow right now like if you're buying
deals you have to buy like an eight to
nine percent return to make sense over
five and a half percent treasuries I'll
tell you this I'm I'm getting 12 to 13
cash on cash returns in Florida in Miami
which is like crazy good but yeah the
houses are a little bit more expensive
like you're gonna need at least
150k or whatever to be able to put a 25
down payment on these houses uh but
Connecticut I'm finding good deals over
there too the only problem is that it's
a blue state but the benefit for me in
Connecticut is uh my family is my
management company so they run it I pay
them and then they you know I invest I
buy and then they go ahead only risk to
you is if a lot more rental inventory
comes on the market that's my biggest
concern is that a lot of people right
now if they don't need to sell they're
going to rent yeah and rental listings
are exploding in terms of what you could
get and I'm worried that if you rent out
today you're gonna be getting a lower
rent a year from now just because
there's going to be more on the market
more for tenants to choose from that
could be the risk that I see yeah I look
at it like when you own though you're in
a good position because sure let's say
yeah because no matter what like you can
either always increase the rents get
another tenant or if it's that bad you
could go buy another house
what you might not necessarily be able
to increase the rents or yeah or again
that's why I said get another tenant but
the other tenant might be at a lower
rate depending on yeah depending on
where you're at like what what I found
was shocking was that and I didn't
really look at rental listings or
anything here in Vegas but Alex's rent
was going up 300 I'm thinking okay let's
just take a look at what's available and
you're finding places now that are
bigger nicer better location for less
money and they're everywhere and we're
looking and they're coming in the market
like several a day yeah within a few
minute distance from here cheaper than
what he's currently yeah Vegas is a
unique thing because you guys are
building out it's true you guys are like
like there's endless land to build on
because you guys are in the middle of a
desert right versus like some of it but
the other part of it is simply people
locking in at low rates can't get the
price they want for sale they'll be
they'll be landlords and so there's just
more coming in the market that people
you know weren't thinking of two years
ago yeah somebody has the same problem
yeah they're just like building out even
more it makes sense so it's a risk but I
think you know if you're cash selling 13
you get a lot of margin on even if you
break even you're still paying down the
mortgage exactly getting benefits so
it's like and it's appreciating at a
good rate too especially Florida Florida
is great for appreciation so are you all
in with the stocks right now then in the
next ones no no I'm a third stocks third
real estate third cash okay basically
and the cash I want to buy more real
estate but I'm just like in a weight and
see approach it right now okay yeah okay
because I'm just not finding any deals
like yeah I want to lock something in at
six and a half percent you could find
that but but it's kind of for all the
work and all the extra stuff it's just
not worth it for that like if I could
get it guaranteed 10 return I would do
it given it you know commercial if you
thought commercial maybe that's what I'm
looking oh you're looking at commercial
okay okay all right yeah that one you
could be a little bit more creative with
increasing otherwise maybe you're
increasing rent or doing whatever yeah
you got to get yeah oh you know who we
had right before you guys with Ben Mala
I don't know if you know oh yeah yeah he
came on our show he's awesome he's
hilarious yeah he's funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh he's hilarious funny listen he's
resting all of us yeah yeah I'm sure he
was but he was telling me to build get
some land and build a commercial space
there's more margin in that yeah and
it's like can you buy yourself a job for
a year and a half two years yeah is that
worth it yes and you got to get a
construction company and everything else
so I told them like if I'm not doing
YouTube and I and I have all the time in
the world I'd love to do something like
that and like be on the job site every
day and just like be a part of it I
loved it yeah it just doesn't make sense
if I'm if your time is split yeah and
you got to be yeah you got to be honest
because then they'll get lazy like they
won't do what they're supposed to do Roi
on a video you make bro versus like all
that work is is it really worth it uh at
some point it will be like I like to
thank the real estate for me is always a
good fallback and I I want to replace
income so if I could be like if I buy
this real estate and it could replace X
income so if the channel something
happens here then I always have that to
fall back on it's like mentally I feel
better with that okay yeah and YouTube
that's the same way I was when I left
the government I was like I'm replacing
my government salary with the real
estate and I was able to do that now I
got another goal of what I want to make
passively but that's the beauty where
like real estate like how many doors do
I need to control to make XYZ amount of
money a month yeah and YouTube is grind
is as you it is so many factors outside
of your control it is time consuming and
the one thing that I've just grown
exhausted of is constantly thinking
about the algorithm yeah just like you
finish a video you feel great for an
hour yep video is doing well fantastic I
could Zona for an hour have a bite to
eat relax but all night I'm thinking
like what's the next topic what's up
next what did I learn from you yeah you
weren't as good as your last video oh I
did say that yeah yeah okay I gotta take
the course only as good as your last
video don't forget that guys that is
true I've got more selective now about
the videos I posted because for years
really since 2021 I've been posting
three videos a week
um regardless so if there's nothing in
the market that's happening I'll find a
topic to talk about I'll come up with
something that I could talk about and
Jack knows it's like every year I've
been like this is the year I'm gonna go
down to two videos a week and I've been
looking for it but then I keep doing
three yeah but I'm down right now to two
videos a week nice so and here's another
thing too like it's got more competitive
with the pandemic right so many new
YouTubers and it's like yeah like I was
watching you back in you know when I was
still agent right because I was like all
right I want to make more money or get
better with my credit uh but now there's
all these other Finance YouTubers that
came on the scene right yeah fantastic
that that's the part that's hard for me
yeah because it's difficult for me now
to compete with all these other channels
who like I feel old in the space at 32 I
feel like I'm ancient and here's some 21
year olds who's coming up who has all
the time in the world who's dedicating
their life to making this one video yeah
and they knock it out of the park and
I'm looking at that thinking that seems
exhausting I don't have the energy for
that anymore yeah so it's it's tough to
compete the thing like back in 2018 when
I was doing this when you would post a
video there were maybe only other 10
other people posting like exactly those
videos so it's easy to stand out but now
when you have a hundred other creators
each posting one of their best videos
and you're spending a month on it but
you get 100 people all spending a month
on it now you have a hundred pieces of
content the bar sits so high that for me
to do that I just don't have the energy
to what the pandemic effectively did was
it created a bunch of new YouTubers
ourselves included and the production
quality went up people spent more time
at home so they were watching YouTube
more than television and now I would I
would say YouTube has effectively
replaced cable television oh yeah you
know what I mean yeah so more more
people tune into YouTube now for
entertainment than like regular TV cable
whatever it may be uh you know fi uh
what is it HBO all that stuff people
don't watch that crap anymore they
stream their entertainment if anything
and Netflix and YouTube so like the
concert creators have like kind of come
on a point where they're damn near TV
level production oh yeah
widely known as like famous people
because that's people watch I guess stop
we get stopped all the time I'm sure you
do too like we get stopped all the time
hey you know sign my book or you change
my life or my I broke up with my toxic
girlfriend because of you you know she
went to the club and I got rid of her I
don't know you know what I mean yeah
it's really it's really great uh you
know to get that that satisfaction but
yeah it's competitive now man how long
do you guys sing uh see yourselves going
in the current route because it I I feel
like in for YouTube in general I think I
mentioned in the program it's like a
five to seven year life span yes and I
I'm approaching six six and a half years
so I'm like the end of my life in terms
of like YouTube that's a good question
man
um well people are already starting to
copy our uh our formula with like
bringing girls on and uh debating them
about intersexual Dynamics uh whatever
podcast I've started to see them a lot
on Tick Tock yeah I wonder why so
um you know a lot of people are
doing what we do which is fine I mean
hey competition is great uh we're just
going to continue to innovate because
our biggest thing where I don't think
anyone touches us is we also talk about
we don't just talk about girls and
debating girls and showing how
delusional a lot of them are we talk
about how to make money how to be
attractive how to actually uh arouse
girls like what what it takes to be like
that dude for the girls so um in command
respect for we bring on crazy guests
that we bring our crazy guests to bring
on let me ask you this do you feel like
potentially the borrower has to keep
getting set higher and higher and higher
like competition so now people have to
get more outrageous more outrageous I'm
worried it's going to get to a point
where all of a sudden Something's Gotta
pop because you can only get so crazy
until eventually something happens and
then the whole thing comes crashing
that's like Prime videos yeah always go
on a travel each video but I think for
us like we had an evaluable for example
like let's say for example you get bored
of watching the girls watch money
Mondays yeah or that you can watch you
know daily videos so it's kind of like
on some level the college shows or when
we bring in special yes a variety of
options you can choose from yeah we
literally hit like every topic we bring
in people that are canceled we're
bringing people we talk about
geopolitics we talk about making money
girls real estate investing how to
become a millionaire uh you know had a
detective a girl isn't worth your time
how to get how to get a date on Tinder
like we talk get your credit scores up
so like we talk about all these
different things so like you'll be able
to find that's why we call ourselves the
number one male self-approving podcast
because we understand that yes girls are
selective nowadays but you got to be
that guy that they select what are some
of the things you guys think you can
personally improve on that's a good
question my speech and also as well for
example
um my fitness for example when I first
came to um
America is really skinny I started
eating food here got fatter and over
time I got Recon place it but now it's
more like if I focus on my fitness and
my health I feel like that's more
important to me than anything else in
the world so thanks for sending speech
uh
build us some more mass I want to own it
I want to weigh more than some of these
these these whales that come on my
podcast and talk smack about me uh I
don't think more what's that you prove
about building more yeah I'm about 200
pounds and six foot three so I need I
need to make some more gains get back uh
you know uh because I still stay in good
shape but I train like four or five
times a week but I need to put a little
bit more muscle mass on and then I would
say man we want to be Rogan level to be
honest with you we want to be at the
level where you know
we're we're like up there with Rogan
like at the Top If we don't get canceled
yeah we don't get canceled that is
hopefully do you worry about that that's
always a thing yeah when you make
content like this where you know you're
very critical about other things we
don't we're not just critical about
women we're critical about a bunch of
different things right the politically
correct you know liberal side of the
internet we're very critical of that so
whenever you make content like that
there's always that risk of that that's
why we're on Rumble as well rumble.com
fresh fit so the rumble uh but yeah and
I think Rumble is going to be huge in
the next couple of years as well because
more and more content creators are going
over there but don't you think now that
you have to do shouldn't you be a lot
more careful in terms of what you say
just because you have a bigger audience
you have more eyeballs on you now it's
worth it to almost scale back in a sense
in terms of controversy just to build
something that that is bigger and more
sustainable so we obviously we play
around it and we the thing is we don't
want to dilute the content right we want
to give the guys the raw information
that they need so what we do is is we'll
typically go live on YouTube and then
like as before we get into the crazy
stuff we'll be all right guys you got to
come on over to rumble now so that we
can really give y'all the sauce
um but you know you have to dance around
certain words and everything else like
that play the YouTube game but uh but
you know we're very aware of the fact
that like you know they canceled Andrew
Tate they cancel snake oh they canceled
a couple of our friends and anytime you
make content that we make where you know
you're seeking the truth they're gonna
get mad and it is what it is so yeah
what's something you guys think you
could work on like more inwards uh
speaking
like like like internal like you mean
like intellectually like like the way
that your brain works mentally something
like that uh we just want to make the
podcast the best I'm constantly
researching like stats on intersexual
Dynamics I'm constantly researching
human evolution and psychology like
self-development type yeah yeah I'm
always reading Finance books so I think
for us to get to that level where we're
like one of the top podcasts in the
world we're there now like we got we're
recognized worldwide but I want to be
like up there like one and two I think
something development never ends of
course yeah uh so no matter what happens
you have to always learn more and become
better but overall for me I think
personally
um just like being better at like I
guess
networking with people
um and internally I would say
maybe just keep reading keep learning
more and never keep innovating keep
pushing the envelope because a lot of
people are trying to do what we're doing
now so we got to continue because I mean
I've said it before we're the
trendsetters here so where no one no one
else was bringing on girls and having
these tough discussions with them until
we started doing it yeah so we just got
to continue to remind everyone why we
said the trends why we're number one in
this and quite frankly none of them are
going to keep up because we're going to
continue to innovate and do different
things what insecurities do you have
like in general yeah not being the best
yeah that's what I'll say is like the
biggest
I want to be up there like top podcast
why more guys need to hear what we're
talking about because I can't tell you
how many DMs I get a day saying I was
going to self-delete nor on YouTube I
was gonna I had a date planned I was
gonna end it all
Etc
I watched this video I finally
understand
why my girl doesn't like me anymore and
the thing is with human nature in
general right all these inventions we
have it comes from the males the humans
need to know right sometimes just
knowing why something happened or
understanding why something happened
will keep you from doing terrible things
to yourself
so if we're able to connect the dots for
someone or tell them yo this is what you
need to really focus on versus focusing
on this girl you need to focus on
yourself Etc it gets rid of that
helplessness and puts guys in a better
position we live in a garden day now
where like men are like almost
second-class citizens no one gives a
crap about men no one cares about their
problems no one cares about their
struggles no one cares about you know
what they're going through and it is
what it is but we give it we give it to
them raw like hey you got to
self-improve and this is what you need
to focus people still do all of that
though without being the best
I feel like there's to reach as many
people as we want to
we got to be the best that they have to
want to listen to you look up to you and
want to be a part of what you're doing
when we ask questions such as like what
is something that I think you can
improve on internally or what is
something that you're self-conscious
about like what I'm what kind of answers
I'm more so Desiring like if I were to
answer those questions what's something
I think I can work on internally is
being more comfortable like if I'm going
out in public I'm not I just don't feel
100 comfortable all the time I'm
dominated by my mind a lot of the time
you know what I mean like I I like I
know it's probably a smart thing to
acknowledge this person or say hello to
this person but my mind's ah you
shouldn't do that something like that's
something where I'm saying internally
something I could do better right maybe
being more present
and then so that's the kind of the
answer I was trying to solicit from you
guys with regards to that question
that's your answer though yeah I know
but then I asked like what is something
that you can work on internally and your
answer was like I just want to be the
best I want the podcast to be the best
there's nothing that you like more
compassionate maybe more understanding
more sympathetic something like that I'm
not saying that these are problems I
have diagnosed in you I'm just curious
in the way that your brain works what
type of that that won't that won't that
won't get to the goal if I'm more
sympathetic or compassionate like no one
cares about my problems or me or caring
about like say oh my God I'm so sorry
for y'all my our job is to give guys the
cold reality of how the world works for
men and give them Solutions I feel like
it it humanizes you to a certain extent
like mine I'm too uptight a lot of the
time and I can't relax and I'm two in my
head I I'm really afraid to let loose
don't know exactly why but I'm like
really rigid and I'm trying to break
that but that makes you who you are
though yeah I don't I but I don't know
if that's necessarily a good quality I
think I think there's a lot of qualities
about letting go being uh not attached
to a certain outcome and being okay with
going with the flow and a very like
structured rigid and I think there are
benefits that I'm missing out on true
but the person that those traits are
those I want to say things that held you
down in that way maybe who you are today
but those things you probably wouldn't
be especially in this spot right now but
I do but I do feel like there's aspects
that I do want to experience that I
haven't and I feel like by letting go a
little bit being a little less stiff I
could enjoy those things okay yeah I
mean you've been on YouTube for a while
you built up a great platform for us
we're not there yet so we gotta continue
to be rigid and like you know keep going
hard like I look at it like I look at
people that are like our competition
I hate them I look at it like we're
gonna beat your faces in like I'm very
very competitive so I look at it like
not only are we going to continue to
outclass you guys and remind you why we
set the trends we're going to make you
guys look stupid in the process and just
lap y'all that's how I look at it like
I'm very I guess you can call it a
negative way to look at it but I hate my
competition that's what fuels me I feel
like it's just the beginning for us sure
yeah we're trying to take over we're
trying to wake more guys up keep guys
from being simps yeah but don't you feel
like there's also something to be said
about lifting other people with you yeah
we're listening we're I'm talking about
competition
for what no them why but what if
they have the same Mission as you
because the end-all be-all isn't like
sure maybe it is to be the best but I
would assume it's also to help what you
diagnosis we're the best at what we do I
don't think they are we're gonna we're
gonna I look at it like their
competition that's cool we're gonna
continue to remind everyone we're the
best and also if that was the case they
would have did it before us not after us
we refused to lose but here's the thing
someone could see what you're doing and
say you know what they're messing up in
these places I'm gonna I'm gonna take
what you're doing but I'm gonna fix
these few things like when I looked on
YouTube originally it was Grant Cardone
Tai Lopez a few people like that I was
looking at what they're doing I'm like
I like it there's an audience for it but
I can do it this way and that's how like
that was my entire approach just seeing
what they're doing but like putting my
own spin on things and I have a feeling
a lot of people will see what you're
doing and find here's a few blind spots
that they're missing maybe they're
they're they're too controversial
they're too this maybe have to take a
more middle approach I'll attract a way
bigger audience well you know what I
said yeah they do the same with that
thing as us so they didn't answer
anything well I think eventually you're
gonna get someone who is
able to see what you're doing and then
put a different spin on it so ever so
slightly and you'll be able to see that
I think those are the people to work
with possibly yeah we'll see
but so far now
yeah I mean for us like we use hey for
me personally I use haters feel like I'm
gonna smack you guys and we're gonna
beat you like that's how I look at it
then when I was an athlete in college
that's how I looked at it uh and that's
how I look at it now like anyone that's
trying to come in our lane and do what
we do I'm like cool yeah congratulations
you guys have just motivated me to
embarrass you even more and do even more
so like we're trying to get bigger
guests yeah we invest more into the
podcast to get better equipment Etc I
look at his fuel because I I truly think
that we're the best we're gonna stay the
best and we're going to continue to
remind everyone whatever but like I
think the things that me and Myron do no
one else can actually really do yeah I
feel like a rising tide lifts all boats
in that sort of sense where like the
more people
get into a certain Niche or an industry
generally the more attention it gets the
more people are able to grow and prosper
because of that
that's just been my experience the
finance would be a great example of that
the finance space and the more people
watching Finance the more my own content
gets recommended so it generally there's
this like this benefit effect where
people circulate from one to another to
another oh no they can raise on their
own
no I mean hey like I said before
competition like like for me I look at
competition as like cool we're gonna
beat their faces in I'm just a very
competitive person there's no oh yeah a
friendly rivalry no we're going to end
you guys we're going to remind you why
you guys are inferior to us so that's
how I look at them approach yeah like I
look at it as like motivation like we're
gonna get better cameras than you guys
we're gonna get uh better guests better
production quality we're gonna film
better content we're gonna script our
stuff better have better questions
whatever it may be so I look at it like
we're just going to provide more value
to the audience like my goal is like how
many more lives can we impact than you
guys that's all look at it and my and to
me like the most satisfying thing is
when like when someone sends me a
message like yo you changed my life yo I
was gonna do this to myself and not not
doing it anymore like the more messages
I get the like that the more of that
that we get than our competition that's
a W for me we wish them all the best
very nice but they're gonna take it out
all right
so overall what I want to say if you
guys feel I feel like I have to sum this
up to some degree please I respect what
you guys do okay I I appreciate the fact
that you guys feel like you have cracked
the code to to dating and you you feel
an obligation to preach to in your minds
improve other people's lives I respect
that tremendously I think everybody
needs to do what they find to be right
at any given moment in their life now if
I were you I would potentially go about
it in a slightly different way I would
try to be a little bit more
compassionate because in my opinion if
you're going around and you call a girl
a hoe or you you are demeaning towards
certain people I think that it will
yield the inverse effect that what
you're setting out to achieve in the
first place I think you're going to
convince other guys that girls can be
hoes and oh I shouldn't talk like yes
sure you shouldn't tolerate but make it
more of an inwards experience rather
than yeah that's their own problem it's
more so like a yeah I'm confident I know
what I deserve sort of thing then like
oh these people they have problems they
don't know what they're doing that's
what I would say
that's it and I think overall I'm happy
you guys came here and I'm happy to
discuss these things yeah fair enough I
mean
I I look at it like guys just need to
protect themselves from girls that don't
deserve relationships because when guys
get in bad relationships that's how they
get their lives ruined so we're our goal
is my thing is I want a guy to be able
to like meet a girl size her up identify
if she's worthy of relationship or not
and then allow him to make the decision
versus having the wool over his eyes and
making a bad decision again you're
saying too 100 however I would just say
like understand like most people I'm not
gonna receive it well if you water it
down I owe 100 and as a provocateur
you're gonna get so many more eyes right
so like if your end goal is what it
seems like it is you'll probably get
more ice therefore more conversions so
you probably will have here's another
thing too but there are un like uh
consequences such as like the byproduct
of like some guy getting the wrong idea
after watching your content yeah and
here's the other thing too that I've
noticed from because we talk with both
men and women with men you have to give
them a very direct and concise solution
to the problem and a lot of times you
can't sugarcoat you got to tell them
yeah you're a fat POS you gotta change
your life you gotta you gotta really
Inspire them right so I yell at guys all
the time like for being loose you guys
Watch Daytime show how I impact them to
like not be losers but with women you
know it needs to be sugar coated and
said in a certain way and they're more
cared about the tonality versus the
message being said so many women
communicate very differently but with
men I notice I have to kick them in the
ass to get them to do something right to
be stop being a fat POS or stop being a
loser to stop smoking pot whatever it is
with women I don't really care what they
think because it's not for them anyway
my thing is for the guys to watch the
podcast and realize how women think for
when I do the podcast and I tell women
like you know what we talk about or I we
have our debates I don't do it for the
girls because they're not going to
change anyway I know they're not gonna
because they already get everything they
want I do it for the guy so that they
understand this is how females think
they don't care what you think
so you need to go in and do what you
want to do and date the same way they do
treat them as Expendable Commodities
just say they treat us like Expendable
Commodities sadly but it's true that's
the truth when it comes to like dating
for men in 2023 if you if you made a
segment directed towards women and I'm
talking about in a in an empowering way
in such a such a way how do I want to
say this in in a way of just like you
got to respect yourself you set
boundaries too if you want to attract
this sort of Guy this is who you have to
become these are ways that you could
improve yourself uh you know these are
things that that you can incorporate
into a communication here's how you can
talk to guys as well I think there's a
lot of things that you could bring to
the table from here so I will say this
with that because because we have had I
get a lot of messages from women that
are married a lot of couples watch our
show actually and it's funny how like
the the people that watch our show the
most that females they typically are in
a relationship or they're married by a
guy right
um here's the thing that I've noticed
with women
when you tell women the unflattering
truths about what it takes to get a man
and keep it most importantly not just
get him but keep him which most modern
day women suck at
they get mad a lot of women can't handle
the truth if I tell them something along
the lines of
be respectful
don't talk too much don't be annoying no
one really cares about your opinion like
that you know uh cooking food you know
when his friends are around make him
look good serve everyone a drink when I
when I say these things right don't be
promiscuous respect yourself dress
modestly don't go out to the club with
your friends most modern day women are
gonna look at me and say what is this
1951 but then they'll turn around right
and they'll expect you if someone
intrudes into the house to protect her
if someone steals a bag they expect you
to chase that guy down and beat him up
they expect you to breathe to be the
breadwinner and pay most of the bills
they want you to be a traditional man
which is cool I agree men should be
traditional but they don't want to be a
traditional woman that's my issue so
when I tell women you want a traditional
man that's going to be chivalrous and
treat you well you need to be a
traditional woman you don't want to do
that traditional man now most women do
that that's what I'm gonna do that's the
problem they want a guy who pays the
bills assertive dominant whatever
because attraction isn't a choice this
is what women are hardwired to want
regardless that's why if she makes 100
per year she still wants you to make
156k per year because they can't choose
that they want a guy that does these
things so my thing is if I tell women
the truth you need to be a traditional
woman to an extent don't be a
protect your youth protect your
fertility get a guy when you're still at
your Peak don't chase a career in
college girls are going to look at me
and say ugh what are you talking about
but this is the truth this is how you
actually get a guy and keep him long
term the problem is that modern day
women are great at attaining a guy but
they suck at retaining a guy after they
have sex
most girls can't handle the truth when I
tell them oh and then accept the fact
that he's gonna probably want to have
sex with other girls that's the biggest
one they can't accept
have a lot of fun though I mean we could
agree to disagree on certain things I
appreciate your fair enough yeah fair
enough final question how happy are you
guys out of 10
. 10 or 10 10 out of 10 man love life
womanizing chilling traveling you know
cars hanging out with you guys any good
I want yeah access glass up networking
appreciate it thank you guys thank you
guys so much for coming on thank you for
having us man it was it was great I
really was awesome thanks for giving us
a time like this fair enough brother
cool thanks for watching guys and until
next time peace